Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Und ich bin auch ein ganz großer Fan von Chaos.
Und ich bin auch ein ganz großer Fan von Chaos. Nein, das machen wir nicht. Wir machen jetzt gleich Chaosradio im Blue Moon am letzten Mittwoch im Monat, heute ein bisschen später, weil wir gerade ein Live-Konzert vom fetten Brot haben. Aber jetzt geht's los. Und wenn ihr mal sehen wollt, wie Leute sozusagen reihenweise explodieren, dann empfehle ich euch, in den Chat zur Sendung zu gehen. Kann mal jemand von den hier Anwesenden, das sind in diesem Fall Huckel und Nibbler, die URL sagen?
Von dem Chat.
Genau, von dem Chat.
Ich bin da über so einen Irrklein drin. Gibt's eine URL für.
Okay, wenn ihr auf Chaosradio.de gebt, dann könnt ihr euch durch das Wiki durchklicken, um dann auf die aktuelle Sendung gehen. Da gibt es den Link zum Chat und auch die Musik, die wir heute noch ganz reich halten. Wir hören jetzt auf. Okay, heute Thema Google. Weil Wiederansicht sind, Google, das nutzt doch eigentlich jeder. Und weil man mal drüber reden wollte, was damit so los ist. Und da gibt es dann auch noch ein paar andere Dienste, die so ähnlich funktionieren. Und das wollen wir alles mal auschecken. Und die erste Frage an euch wäre tatsächlich. Und im ganz Allgemeinen nutzt ihr Google? Und wenn ja, welche Dienste von denen? 0331 70 97 110 Zum Beispiel die ganzen Leute, die im Chat schon die ganze Zeit gemeckert haben, dass jetzt endlich das Chaosradio losgehen soll, die können jetzt mal anrufen hier. Bin mal gespannt, ob die sich trauen. So, Fuckel und Nibler sind wie gesagt hier, um genau mit euch über dieses Thema zu sprechen. Kurze Einführung. Was ist eigentlich das Problem?
Das Problem?
Okay, gibt es ein Problem mit Google?
Das wollen wir sozusagen hier in dieser Sendung auch erarbeiten. Also eigentlich reden wir jetzt nicht darüber, weil das jetzt einen besonderen Anlass gibt, sondern mich persönlich hat so über die letzten Wochen so ein Gefühl erschlichen, so ein mulmiges Gefühl. Ich hab so überlegt, was gibt es denn eigentlich alles von Google? Was benutze ich denn da so? Was sammeln die eigentlich alles für Daten von mir? Getragen auch von so ein paar Schlagzeilen in den letzten Tagen. Google Buzz und irgendwelche Kommentare von der Innenministerin, Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger ist sie Innenministerin? Justizministerin?
Guck doch mal auf Google.
Genau, und dadurch kam sozusagen die Idee, wir könnten ja mal ein bisschen über Google sprechen, weil irgendwie so ich immer mehr das Gefühl hab, dass sozusagen den Leuten gar nicht so richtig bewusst ist, was da alles so passiert. Also wem sie da die Daten geben und was sie alles so für Daten geben und ob das überhaupt ein Problem ist.
Das?
Oder eben auch nicht, genau.
Also ganz kurz, wir haben jetzt noch eine 1, 5 Stunden Zeit, um das zu klären, aber so ein kurzer Ausblick, ist es ein Problem, ja oder nein?
Also ich sehe es, kommt drauf an, kommt auf die Perspektive an. Also es gibt da auf jeden Fall so eine Ambivalenz, also es ist auf jeden Fall ganz klar, jeder benutzt tagtäglich 10, 20, 30, 100 mal irgendeinen Google-Dienst.
Das würde ich jetzt wirklich gerne noch mal wissen. Welche Google-Dienste gibt es denn überhaupt?
Genau, aber das ist nämlich so der erste Punkt gewesen. Erstmal die Überlegungen, was gibt es eigentlich für Google-Dienste? Also ich habe jetzt hier so eine Sammlung, wir haben so eine Sammlung erarbeitet, die können wir mal ganz kurz nur vielleicht erst mal beim Namen nennen. Also es gibt Gmail, E-Mail von Google, es gibt einen Kalender, es gibt Maps von Google, es gibt Documents, wo man Word-Documents und Spreadsheets bei Google hosten kann. Es gibt den Dienst Latitude, mit dem man sagen kann, wo man sich gerade auffällt und sozusagen sagen, anderen Freunden sagen kann, ich bin gerade in New York und wenn ihr auch da seid, trefft mich.
Ich dachte, dafür gibt es Twitter.
Na, es gibt auch dieses Latitude. Dann gibt es Contacts, das ist jetzt ein Beta-Dienst, eigentlich sowieso schon immer da, aber auch ein eigener Dienst zum Kontakte, hosten und synchronisieren. Es gibt Google Analytics, was man auf seine eigene Webseite einbinden kann, um genaue Statistiken von den Besuchern der Webseite zu erhalten. Es gibt Google Desktop. Also das würde mich zum Beispiel auch mal interessieren, also diese Applikationen, die von Google sind, die man sich auf dem eigenen Rechner installiert. Google Desktop durchsucht die eigene Festplatte, indexiert sie und man kann dann halt mit Google Technologie ganz schnell seine Dateien finden. Dann gibt es seit kurzem einen Browser. Es gibt natürlich AdSense und AdWords. Also das ist eigentlich das Core-Geschäft, könnte man sagen, von Google.
Man muss jetzt aber auch kurz erklären, was das ist.
Ja, natürlich. Also Google verdient ja, würde ich behaupten, das Hauptgeld immer noch mit dem Schalten von Werbung und der personalisierten Anzeige von Werbung. Und da gibt es eben zwei Dienste AdSense und AdWords. Das heißt, man kann sich zum Beispiel auf seinem eigenen Blog Google-Werbung schalten lassen und... Genau, kriegt auch anteilig Geld dafür, wenn da irgendwie sozusagen Revenue entsteht, ja.
Man kann das Geld aber auch gleich wieder ausgeben für Werbung bei Google, kann aber auch Werbung bei Google für Geld schalten.
Genau. Also...
Wenn ihr mich fragt, hört ihr das alles super an?
Ich meine...
Genau, ja warte, das geht noch weiter mit dem großen Spaß. Es gibt auch noch ein Chatprogramm, ein G-Talk von Google. Google hat auch einen Bloggerdienst, also falls du bloggen willst, bietet da Google auch die passende Variante. Es gibt Mailinglisten, es gibt Bilderhostingdienst, es gibt einen Code-Hostingdienst für deine Programmierprojekte, es gibt eine RSS-Räder, sie indexieren auch Bücher...
Warte, warte, könnte sein, dass es kürzer wird, wenn du erklärst, was es nicht gibt. Also Dinge, die man mit dem Computer machen kann und die es von Google nicht gibt. Gibt es sowas noch?
Also ich müsste auf jeden Fall lange überlegen, bis mir jetzt spontan was einfällt. Es gibt sicherlich noch was, aber es ist halt schon so, dass wenn man das Ganze sozusagen aufzählt, dass sich der Eindruck erschleicht einem, dass die schon versuchen, das gesamte digitale Leben, naja die Essenz davon, unter einem Firmennamen, unter einem Logo zu vereinen.
Hast du nicht eigentlich noch was vergessen? Die haben auch eine Suchmaschine, habe ich gehört.
Genau, die wollte ich eigentlich zum Schluss nennen.
Okay, die Liste ist ja jetzt schon ziemlich lang. Wir haben jetzt gerade Yvonne dran. Und wir werden mal hören, was die so nutzt. Hallo Yvonne.
Hallöchen, ja.
Du nutzt Google oder nicht?
Ich nutze Google sehr, sehr viel. Als Suchmaschine, das als erstes brauche ich tagtäglich auf Arbeit. Google Maps brauche ich auch für meine Arbeit, um zu gucken, ja, Mensch, wo wohnen die Leute?
Halt, bevor du jetzt weitere Dienstherdienste, die du für deine Arbeit brauchst, was arbeitest du denn?
Ich bin Personalvermittler.
Halt, genau.
Da gehört Google natürlich zum...
Und brauche, ja, wenn die jetzt in Buxtehude wohnen, muss ich natürlich gucken, weiß ja nicht, wie weit ist es jetzt bis zum Arbeitsplatz, wo ich eventuell einen Kunden hab, ist es erreichbar mit dem Auto und und, kann man das dem Arbeitnehmer zumuten? Also suche ich über Google Maps, gib meine Postleitzahlen ein und weiß, Mensch, halt sind 90 Kilometer, brauche ich den Bewerber nicht anrufen.
Und suchst du auch die Leute, die du da vermittelst, dann bei Google raus?
Ist ja für eine Webseite, ist Google auch sehr, sehr, ja, gibt sehr viele Richtlinien vor. Nebenbei wurde auch schon angesprochen, Google Analytics, über welche Suchworte kommen meine Bewerber?
Ah, warte, interessante Frage, nutzt du das?
Ja, wird bei uns in der Firma genutzt.
Weißt du, dass die Datenschützer in Deutschland der Ansicht sind, dass das illegal ist?
Also, ja, man kann ja dieses... Ich bin jetzt nun nicht so ein Seeufrig und hab dann so ein bisschen Halbwissen, aber ich hab jetzt schon in der ganzen Arbeit mitbekommen, Google ändert alle paar Wochen, Monate ihre Richtlinien eine Zeit lang, durfte man zum Beispiel in Webkataloge, sagt vielleicht auch ziemlich vielen Leuten was, wurde für Marketingzwecke, für eine Webseite viel genutzt und Google hat dann irgendwann mal gesagt halt stopp, man darf nie denselben Content verwenden. Also ja, da richten sich denn die ganzen Webdesigner, na Webdesigner nicht, also alle die Suchmaschinenoptimierung, Marketing betreiben, die ja richten sich nach Google, um das Ranking bei Google besser zu platzieren.
Okay, das ist glaube ich mal ein ganz anderes Problem, das wir heute auch nicht so sehr besprechen wollen, nämlich dieses Google-Suche und das... Warte, Yvonne, warte, pass auf, das Ding ist, die Sendung hat ganz spät angefangen und jetzt sitzt uns schon wieder das Format im Nacken. Wir müssen jetzt erstmal Nachrichten machen. Bleibt dran, Hörer auch dranbleiben. Wir machen jetzt erstmal Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr und dann geht es gleich und sofort weiter.
Live und neu und gut.
Fritz empfiehlt.
Auch live im Magnet Club Berlin.
Wann genau und wo genau?
Live von Neu und Gut, empfohlen von...
Von... Nachrichten mit Martin Schneider. In Brandenburg können Schüler aus sozial schwachen Familien in Zukunft kostenlos zur Schule und wieder nach Hause fahren. Der Landtag stimmte heute einen entsprechenden Antrag der Fraktionen von SPD und Linkspartei zu. Zur Begründung hieß es Kinder aus Familien, die Sozialleistungen beziehen, müssten die gleichen schulischen Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten haben wie alle übrigen Kinder. Die FDP wollte, dass alle Schüler kostenlos fahren können, das wurde aber abgelehnt. Der Führerschein mit 17 soll zur Regel werden. Bis zum Ende des Jahres soll das gesetzlich umgesetzt werden, das kündigte Bundesverkehrsminister Ramsauer an. Er sagte, dass begleitende Fahren bringe mehr Sicherheit für junge Fahranfänger. Als erstes Bundesland hatte im Jahr 2004 Niedersachsen den Führerschein mit 17 eingeführt. Dabei dürfen junge Fahranfänger bis sie 18 sind, nur in Begleitung eines Erwachsenen an Steuern. Die UNO hat strengere Maßnahmen gegen sogenannte K.O.-Tropfen gefordert. Zurzeit sind diese Tropfen offenbar das größte Problem in der Drogenszene. Das steht in einem Bericht der Vereinten Nationen. Demnach ist eine gründliche Aufklärungskampagne über die Gefahren erforderlich. K.O.-Tropfen werden oft auf Partys unbemerkt ins Getränk gemischt. Opfer können sich dadurch gegen sexuelle Übergriffe kaum wehren. Oft erinnern sie sich nicht einmal daran. In der zweiten Fußball-Bundesliga hat Union Berlin am Abend ein Auswärtsspiel bei Hansa Rostock gehabt. Das Spiel endete 0 zu 0 unentschieden. Und die aktuellen Temperaturen. In Neuropin und Angermünde haben wir 0 Grad, in Potsdam, Frankfurt und Wittenberge sind es ein, in Cottbus 2 und in Berlin um die 1 Grad. Nachts ist es wolkig mit etwas Regen, im Norden gibt es vereinzelt noch Schnee. Die Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen plus zwei und minus einen Grad. Morgen ist es dann auch wieder mit Tauwetter alles gesegnet, mit Temperaturen zwischen sieben und elf Grad. Und ab und zu kann es etwas regnen oder diese regnen. Mit nur zwei Meldungen, B 198 Gramm zur Angermünde. Zwischen Greifberg gibt es, ach nee, bei Greifberg, pardon, bei Greifenberg in beiden Richtungen Vollsperrung, da gab es einen Unfall mit einem LKW. Und aus dem Stadtverkehr Berlin, B 101, Altemarien-Dorf, bei Großbeerenstraße. Zwischen der Großbeerenstraße und Langwitzer Straße ist ein Fahrstreifen gesperrt. Was ist heute los? Da gab es einen Unfall. Da wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5, dann Fritz in Eisenhüttenstadt.
Die 2 Sprechstunden. Einen anderen Teil sind es noch mit Markus Richter, Huckel und Nibbler vom Chaos Computer Club, weil heute ist Chaos Radio letzter Mittwoch im Monat ganz klar. Wir wollen halt über Google reden und haben erst mal angefangen, alle Dinge aufzuzählen, die Google so anbietet und haben festgestellt, das ist eigentlich so alles.
Genau, wir haben noch nicht mal alle.
Wir haben noch nicht alle hier aufgemistet, aber es ist im Prinzip alles, könnte man sagen. Also die meisten Dinge, die man mit dem Computer machen, kann man auch da machen.
Eine wichtige Sache, würde ich noch sagen, also Telefon, Stichwort Telefon, Android Telefon haben sie auch noch. Und ein Betriebssystem kommt eben auch noch.
Die Android Telefone synchronisieren natürlich auch brav die Kontakte mit Google Contacts.
Also voll integriert im Google Versum sozusagen.
Super, ich muss mir gar keine Gedanken mehr machen. Okay, wir hatten gerade, wir wollen aber heute auch von euch wissen, wie viel Google nutzt ihr und wie viele Gedanken macht euch darüber? 0331 70 97 110 Und Yvonne hat angerufen und hat schon erklärt, dass sie Google ganz viel für Arbeit nutzt. Mich würde jetzt noch interessieren, Yvonne, nutze Google auch privat?
Ja, fiel mir noch ein sehr schöner Programm ein, Google Earth. Wo man sich wirklich, die ganze Welt sind zwar sehr veraltete Fotografien, die man da so teilweise sieht, aber sehr, sehr schöne Programme umzugucken. Mensch, wo fahr ich in den nächsten Urlaub hin? Um mir vorab schon mal so ein bisschen die Gegend anzugucken.
Das heißt, du wirst auch von der Einführung von Street View ganz begeistert sein, hier in Deutschland?
Ja.
Dieses Programm, wo man sich quasi durch die Stadt scrollen kann, wie ein Computerspiel.
Ganz tolle Sache.
Und das war's aber. Du hast irgendwie so Chat oder Documents oder...
Die drei Sachen sind erstmal sehr, sehr ausschlaggebend. Die brauch ich.
Wenn ihr auch noch was zu berichten habt, wenn ihr auch Google nutzt oder wenn ihr Google nicht nutzt und auch sozusagen einen guten Grund dafür habt, außer Verpeilung, dann gerne hier anrufen. 0331 70 97 110. So, weiter geht's hier. Wir haben jetzt also das ganze Kram, den ganzen Kram. Und Nibbler wird dabei immer ein bisschen anders. Warum?
Naja, weil jede Frage an Google gleichzeitig auch eine Antwort vor Google ist. Wenn ich nach einer bestimmten Sache frage, weiß Google, dass ich mich für was interessiere. Wenn ich meine Kontakte da hochlade, dann können sie darüber frei verfügen. Und Google macht quasi das, was sie schon immer machen. Sie machen rohe Daten, die sie so bekommen, urbar. Und bieten einem dafür natürlich auch einen gewissen Mehrwert an. Da ist dann die Frage, ist der Mehrwert, den ich davon kriege, ist das okay? Ist das irgendwas, wovon ich profitiere? Ist es okay, dass ich mit meinen Datenführen einen gewissen Dienst bezahle, sozusagen? Und das in erster Linie in der Form, dass ich da natürlich Werbung eingeblendet bekomme, die zu meinen E-Mails passt oder was auch immer. Oder ob mir da so ein bisschen mulmig dabei ist, weil es doch schon echt viele Dinge sind, die, wenn man als Google Fanboy alle Services nutzt, da ist das schon ein sehr guter Überblick, den Google da überhand die Persönlichkeit bekommt.
Aber warum ist das schlimm?
Ich sag nicht, dass das schlimm ist, das ist nur die Frage, was gebe ich Google an Daten? Wie viel Daten gebe ich Google unbewusst? Bin ich mir selber darüber im Klaren, dass eine Frage an Google für die auch gleichzeitig eine Antwort ist?
Genau, das ist eigentlich so der Punkt, der mir sozusagen mulmiges Gefühl macht, ist eigentlich so das Unwissen darüber, was überhaupt alles für Daten anfallen. Also wie gesagt, ich würde gar nicht mal sagen, jetzt ist Evil, Daten zu sammeln oder was auch immer. Also klar aus Datenschützersicht oder ich glaube, wie war das, private Daten schützen, öffentliche Daten nutzen, ist ja sozusagen eins der, wie ist denn die Mehrzahl von Motto? Eins der Motten des CCC. Also als Datenschützer klar, so wenig Daten anhäufen wie möglich, aber auch aus so öffentlich, also als Normal-User-Sicht sozusagen, ist einem halt auch einfach gar nicht klar, was da gesammelt wird. Man hört immer viel, man liest immer viel, man stellt sozusagen eine Liste auch von Produkten, die sie anbieten und fragt sich dann halt so, was passiert da eigentlich? So und wenn man da halt so ein bisschen nachguckt und dann nachrecherchiert und vielleicht kann man das ja im Rahmen dieser Sendung auch noch so ein bisschen erläutern, was überhaupt für Daten da anfallen und wie die gesammelt werden, entsteht dann halt auch ein Persönlichkeitsprofil von einem. Das muss jetzt nicht unbedingt direkt genutzt werden, aber ja, es ist halt da.
Es stehen auf jeden Fall Daten.
Ja, also wie gesagt, das mulmige Gefühl bei mir ist eigentlich die Frage, was ist denn da überhaupt alles von mir gespeichert und muss das eigentlich sein?
Das soll nicht mal bedeuten, dass Google damit irgendwie jetzt was vor hat mit den Daten, sondern allein das Faktum, dass da Daten zusammengeführt werden, dass da Daten gespeichert werden. Ist schon sowas, kann ich Google zutrauen, auf diese Daten aufzupassen? Kann ich Google, also kann ich Google insoweit? Bin ich davor sicher, dass diese Daten von jemandem genutzt werden, von jemandem genutzt werden, von dem ich das nicht möchte? Und das ist eben bei auch den Standardeinstellungen, die man, wenn man so ein Google Service nutzt, da ist erstmal der Datensaugrüssel voll aufgedreht. Man muss nach den Privacy-Optionen suchen, die Funktionen, um Privacy-Einstellungen zu tätigen, um Datenschutzoptionen zu aktivieren, im Google Browser, Google Chrome, ist im vierten Untertab irgendwo versteckt. Man muss sie erstmal finden und aktivieren. Das ist schon eine interessante Grundeinstellung, mit der Google da so rangeht.
Na klar, sie wollen ganz viele Daten haben, weil sie ja letztendlich darüber auch ihr Geld einnehmen. Weil dann gibt es ja wieder bessere Werbung mit mehr Daten. Genau. Und die Frage, die du gerade gestellt hast, kann ich dem Google zutrauen, auf meine Daten aufzupassen, hatte Eric Schmidt, einer der Chefs von Google, was Schönes gesagt, nämlich das hier. Also sinngemäß, wenn du nicht willst, dass irgendwas über dich bekannt wird, dann solltest du es vielleicht einfach gar nicht machen. Das hat er gesagt auf die Nachfrage, dass viele Leute Google ja als ihren besten Freund behandeln, ob das so okay wäre. Und hat danach noch weiter ausgeführt, dass natürlich alle Informationen auch irgendwie abrufbar sind, vom Staat zumindest, weil in den USA gibt es ein Patriot Act. Wir haben hier so schicke Sachen wie die Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Aber er hat auch was anderes gesagt. Und anderes gesagt.
Wir versuchen, auf der endlosen Seite der Privilege zu bleiben.
Wenn wir so etwas geben würden und es in Formen mindern, die dich als Einzelnehmung befüren würden, dann würden unsere Kunden unsere Widerstandsfälle bewegen.
Kurz zusammengefasst, er sagt halt irgendwie, klar wir haben ganz viele Daten, aber wir nutzen die halt nicht sozusagen in der ganz krassen Form, weil wenn wir das machen würden, würden alle User bei uns abhauen.
Das war in der Tat so ein Motto von Google, don't be evil, also dass sie die Daten nicht in der Hand nehmen, sondern sie in der Hand nehmen, und das ist ein ganz krasser Punkt. Und ich glaube, das ist ein ganz krasser Punkt, weil wir nicht nur die Daten in der Hand nehmen, sondern wir haben auch die Daten in der Hand, die wir außen hin versuchen, dem Nutzer ein angenehmes Gefühl zu geben, so deine Daten sind bei uns so sicher, wie du die gerne haben möchtest. Wir bieten dir Privacy-Optionen an. Wir verraten dir auch ein Stück weit, was für Daten wir über dich sammeln. Kann man sich auf irgendeiner Seite tief versteckt bei den diversen Google-Produkten auch anzeigen lassen. Das ist in der Tat auch das Problem. Wenn mal groß in der Presse ist, Google hat mit den und den Daten Diss und Dis gemacht und hat irgendwie User ausspioniert, dann haben sie ein handfestes PR-Problem. Also haben durchaus dann Nutzer, die sagen, ok, da läuft was falsch und die nutzen dann ihre Produkte nicht mehr. Ist allerdings die Frage, was gibt es da groß für Alternativen?
Also das war auch eine interessante Frage. Ich kenne Leute, die sind tatsächlich von Google weggegangen, weil denen das irgendwann zum Bund war. Dann haben sie anderen Diensten zugewendet. Also falls ihr immer Google genutzt habt und gesagt habt, nein, das will ich lieber nicht mehr, ich geh woanders hin. Dann würde uns interessieren, wohin denn? Ich habe zum Beispiel, ich kenne jemanden, der ist von Google zu Mobile Me gegangen, also diesem Apple-Dienst, der quasi auch diese ganzen Datenverwaltung, also Kalender zumindest und Kontakte und das alles bietet, aber halt gegen Geld. Und Argument, was man auch häufig hört, ist, ja ich bezahle dafür, denn wenn ihr mit meinem Daten keinen Schindler treiben. Ist das so? Kann man das dann so sagen? Also bei Google ist das Problem, die brauchen die Daten, müssen die verarbeiten, weil sie sonst kein Geld einnehmen.
Ja, aber ich meine, genau das wäre halt der größte anzunehmende Unfall, sozusagen, wenn bei denen ein Datenlink entsteht, weil dann sofort alle, und wirklich alle, die die ganze Zeit sagen, irgendwie das ist evil, die speichern zu viele Daten. Wir haben es euch ja die ganze Zeit gesagt, und jetzt ist es passiert, und jetzt habt ihr den Salat, ja. Die wurden halt alle sofort auf die Bühne kommen und losschreien und ein riesiges Toberwurf lösen. Deswegen sind die da wahrscheinlich schon extrem bemüht, einfach die Daten beisammenzuhalten. Das würde ich denen auch durchaus zutrauen. Also, wie gesagt, ich würde ihnen gar keine bösen Absichten unterstellen.
Das gehört ein Stück weit zu ihrem Geschäftskonzept.
Aber sozusagen der Umkehrschluss auch, wenn ich gar nicht will, dass meine Daten verarbeitet werden, dann nehme ich einfach einen Dienst, den man bezahlen muss.
Dass man für einen Dienst bezahlt, heißt nicht, dass der Dienst auf die Daten besser aufpassen kann.
Was ihr auch gesagt habt, ist nicht nur die Möglichkeit, dass so etwas nach außen dringend kann, sondern auch, dass es diese ganzen Dienste gibt, und das kann man quasi alles zusammenrechnen. Das macht Google ja auch irgendwie.
Bei Google bezahlt man im Prinzip auch darüber, dass man sich ihre Werbeeinbindung anguckt, für die sie natürlich auch mehr Geld bekommen.
Der Unterschied ist aber so groß gar nicht. Genau, das war die eigentliche Frage. Also der Unterschied zwischen einem Dienst, dem man nicht bezahlt und all seine Daten ablegt, und einem Dienst, dem man bezahlt und all seine Daten ablegt, ist letztendlich Latte.
Genau. Also der wesentliche Punkt ist einfach, es fallen Daten an, die liegen bei irgendjemanden und man hat halt keine Kontrolle drüber.
Aber das heißt wiederum, als ob sich nur die Frage stellt, entweder Online-Daten abspeichern oder offline. Aber wir leben 2010, Leute. Ich möchte nicht mehr mein Telefon irgendwie anstöpseln müssen oder von Hand. Ich will bitte, dass das ganz automatisch sich alles synchronisiert.
Und wenn man sich absolut sicher gehen möchte, dass deine schlüpfrigen Fotos nicht im Internet auftauchen, dann sorgt man sich darum, dass die Fotos nicht Richtung Internet kommen.
Ja, aber dann steckst du mal kurz dein Android-Telefon an dein Rechner und singst mal kurz mit Google und schwupp, landen sie in deinem Picasa-Account.
Ja, gut, das mit den schlüpfrigen Fotos oder Party-Militärn ist ja quasi... Ich glaube, die meisten haben mittlerweile begriffen, dass man das nicht macht, aber es geht ja eher um die ganzen privaten Daten, die man hat. Also möchte z.B. mein Kontakt, also mein Adressbuch, möchte ich nicht, dass das irgendjemand in die Finger kriegt oder dass das automatisch weiterverarbeitet wird.
Genau, das ist ja gerade kürzlich erst passiert. Auch wieder so ein Punkt, wo ich dachte, na, so richtig gefällt mir das aber nicht. Hatten sie ja diesen neuen Social-Network-Dienst. Also du hast dich bei Gmail eingeloggt und durftest dann auf den Buzz-Button klicken. Was sie aber nicht gesagt haben, war, dass sie dann auch automatisch deine Kontakte oder deine E-Mails sozusagen analysieren und gucken, mit wem du so kommunizierst und die automatisch zu deinen Followern hinzugefügt haben.
Also um das mal ganz klar zu machen, was das bedeutet, das hat zum Beispiel bedeutet, es gibt einen Blogpost aus den USA, da hat eine Frau relativ viele Mails von ihrem Ex-Mann oder Ex-Freund bekommen, der auch gewalttätig war und sie gestalkt hat. Und naja, sie hatte halt viele Mails von dem im Postfach, also war es ja offensichtlich ein guter Kontakt, also ist ja bei Buzz als ihr Follower freigeschaltet worden.
Genau.
Ist das quasi ein kleiner Vorgeschmack auf die Dinge, die passieren können, wenn man nur bei Zoom, wenn man alle seine Daten bei einer Firma erstarrt bringt?
Das würde ich mal sagen, ist prinzipiell immer ein Szenario, aber bei Google ist auf jeden Fall natürlich dadurch, dass sie eben so viele Dienste unter einem Hut bringen, ist ja die Bequemlichkeit, die dann jeder Service mitbringt, auch extrem hoch, man hat nur einen Account und so weiter. Und sie versuchen halt natürlich auch, das zusammenzuführen. Aus diesen ganzen verschiedenen Accounts und Diensten, möglichst halt dem Nutzer auch eine noch bequemere, noch automatischere, noch benutzerfreundlichere Atmosphäre zu schaffen. Dass man halt sich um wirklich nichts mehr kümmern muss. Telefon anspülen, sinken, fertig. Computer an, Kontakte gesynkt, bringen, fertig.
Also auch generell die Frage, also was wäre eine Gesellschaft, wo jeder alles über jeden weiß? Ist das so das Extrem, was da am anderen Ende zu einer totaler Privatsphäre steht?
Ja, könnte man sich gut vorstellen.
Also ich meine, das ist...
Jeder weiß alles immer, das heißt, man hätte so eine Art...
Man wüsste dann, ob jemand gar nicht wissen will.
Open Stasi.
Aber einerseits, ich glaube, es gibt nur zwei Bücher, einerseits würden dann alle Sitten total verrohen, weil es eh egal ist, weil es eh egal ist, oder es wäre so eine ganz verklemmte Gesellschaft. So ein bisschen die Kalvinisten in den Jännern quasi. Okay, wir haben jetzt David am Start. Der nutzt Google aber nicht viel. Hallo David.
Hallo, geht er relativ schnell heute sogar.
Entschuldigung, wir können nicht nochmal rausstellen.
Wir haben ein fettes Brotschleife spielen.
Nee, ich nutze Google nicht soweit. Vor allen Dingen den E-Mail dient es auch nicht. Ich habe zum Beispiel einen Kumpel, der nutzt den. Und sagt aber auch selber, Google ist evil. Ich weiß das. Ich bin auch sonst datenschutztechnisch relativ vorsichtig. Aber ich kann nicht mehr darauf verzichten.
Okay, dann drängen Sie mir zwei Fragen auf.
Na, er sagt es aus den Gründen, weil die halt alle Daten sammeln, alle möglichen Daten. Und weil dieser Fakt alleine schon zu dem Gedanken führt, dass sie die zu Zecken verwenden können, die wir nicht nachvollziehen können.
Und er bestellt, dass sie das auch machen?
Ja, er betrachtet die Möglichkeit auf jeden Fall. Bestellen tut er das im gewissen Sinne auch, aber ich schätze, er ist einfach mal moderat formuliert.
Wieso nutzt er dann Gmail weiter? Was bringt ihn dann dazu, Google Mail weiterhin zu nutzen?
Na, er sagt einfach, die ganzen Optionen, die die bieten, die sind einfach in dem Umfang überhaupt nicht in allen möglichen anderen E-Mail-Anbietern vorhanden. Was ich mir vorstellen kann, ich weiß es jetzt nicht genau, also die haben irgendwie viel zu gute Einstellmöglichkeiten und Optionen und Möglichkeiten, die andere Dienste nicht haben. Und deswegen kommt er einfach nicht mehr davon weg und will davon nicht mehr wegkommen. Und dann hab ich ihm gesagt, ja gut, ich werd's auf jeden Fall nicht machen, schon allein aus dem Grund, dass ich keinen Blut lecken will.
Wie bitte?
Es macht dich total kaputt, aber es ist geil.
Genau, ich hab ihm dann gesagt, ich werd's aus dem Grund schon mal alleine nicht machen, weil ich die Angst hab, dass es mir genauso geht wie ihm und ich dann nicht mehr davon wegkomme.
Und was nutzt du von Google gar nichts?
Nee, gar nichts, außer halt Google als Suchmaschine, aber sonst nix.
Aber hast du einen Google Account?
Nutzt du die Möglichkeit, in deinem Browser Cookies reinzuschränken oder?
Ob ich die nutze? Die nutze ich schon, ja.
Also die Frage wird jetzt darauf, Google ist ja auch ohne Account speichert, ist deine ganze Suche am Fragen und wertet die aus, aber halt nicht über einen Account, sondern halt über die Daten, die in deinem Cookie abgespeichert sind.
Ja, ja, okay, klar, ja, gut, das mach ich schon. Also das, wo die Suche an Fragen gespeichert, aber ja, ich hab wie gesagt bei denen keine E-Mail Adresse und werd auch bei denen keiner neben mich bin, bei den üblichen Anbietern im Internet.
Warum sind die besser als Google?
Wie bitte?
Die sind ja nicht besser als Google. Weil ich mit denen erst mal so ganz gut zufrieden zurechtkomme. Ich hab jetzt noch nicht so den größten Grund, zu Google zu gehen. Wenn ich den Speicherplatz höre, den die IMA zum Beispiel anbieten, ist das natürlich schon eigentlich ein Grund eventuell, aber bis jetzt hat es mich noch nicht so getrieben. Also ich komm mit den restlichen Anbietern gut klar. Und deswegen bin ich noch nicht zu Google gewechselt und auch alleine, weil ich, wenn ich diese ganzen Sachen sehe, die Google macht, mit den Informationen sammeln, weil ich das auch gar nicht so möchte.
Okay, aber sie machen...
Ich Google meine Informationen, um nicht unbedingt zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Aber was sie ja trotzdem machen, ist deine Suchanfragen auswerten.
Ja, gut klar.
Aber das ist dir egal?
Na egal ist mir das auch nicht. Also das würde ich am liebsten auch verhindern wollen. Ich benutze auch teilweise deswegen Xquick.
Was ist das?
Das ist eine alternative Suchmaschine, die vollkommen auf Transparenz und Privacy setzt. xquick.com Aber die nutze ich halt auch nur teilweise, weil man nimmt dann halt teilweise doch schon Google noch.
Weil?
Ist halt im Browser.
Die Bequemlichkeit ist dann teilweise im Browser, wenn man mal an anderen Rechnern ist und vielleicht ist dann einmal eine Suche an Frage nicht so genau wie bei xquick vorhanden und so.
Also eine Gewöhnungssache, also man weiß, wie gut man gehen muss.
Xquick hat auch nicht so den extremen guten Server wie Google, deswegen teilweise ganz selten auch mal zu Überlastung gekommen. Aber einfach auch so Gewohnheit, dass man Google weiter benutzt.
Man gewöhnt sich bei so einer Suchmaschine, hab ich zumindest in der Vergangenheit festgestellt, enorm schnell und intuitiv dran, was man für Suchworte eingeben muss. Das ist bei jeder Suchmaschine so ein bisschen anders, wie man seine Suchanfrage formulieren muss, um ein bestimmtes Ergebnis zu bekommen. Viel ist da einfach auch Gewöhnung.
Also der Vorteil, den Google hat, ist, es funktioniert einfach. Könnte man sagen, das geht uns hier bei Fritz auch so. Wir nutzen zum Beispiel Google Talk, also semioffizielles Instant-Messaging-Medium, hier unter den Leuten, die im Sender arbeiten. Obwohl wir die wunderbare Software Lotus haben. Die bietet auch einen Instant-Messaging-Dienst. Also wer jetzt nicht weiß, was Lotus ist, Lotus ist ein E-Mail-Programm, das wurde ungefähr 1923 geschrieben, bedient sich auch so, ist aber noch ein bisschen langsamer als eine Dampfmaschine.
Das ist ungefähr so der Vergleich, einlagiges und fünflagiges Klopapier. Der Vorteil liegt auf der Hand.
Das muss ich bei unserem Technik-Chef sagen.
Was ich aber sehr bedenklich finde, ist, dass die mit den Autos rumfahren und die ganzen Straßen in Deutschland filmen.
Warum?
Auch so eine Sache, wo ich sage, muss nicht unbedingt sein. Weil das hat ja eventuell noch nicht mal was mit Datenschutz zu tun. Beziehungsweise hat es schon. Jetzt haben sie es ja aufgeweicht, dass sie gesagt haben, sie machen die Kennzeichnungen unkenntlich und die Gesichter. Aber grundsätzlich finde ich, dass es einfach nicht nötig ist, dass die Deutschen und Berliner und allen möglichen Straßen in Deutschland hier dokumentieren.
Ich möchte ganz kurz mal reinhaken. Die haben das vorgestellt. Dienstag Vormittag hat Google die deutsche Version von Google Street View vorgestellt. Da ging es auch genau um dieses automatische Unkenntlich-Machen von Gesichter und Kennzeichen. Die haben einen ganz langen Vortrag gehalten, warum das alles toll ist. Währenddessen kam auch die Frage auf, wie zuverlässig funktioniert das denn? Da sagte der Raphael Leiteritz, der Produktmanager von Google Maps, also der Software, die quasi über Street View steht oder wo Street View auch drunter fällt, naja, so wenige Prozent. Ich wollte das nachher noch mal genauer wissen, als wir mit meinem kleinen Aufnahmengeld ging, haben wir gesagt, so Herr Leiteritz, wie hoch ist denn jetzt die Fehlerquote bei diesem automatischen Unkenntlichmachung von Gesichtern und Kennzeichen?
Die Technologie ist sehr, sehr gut. Das ist die beste, die es auf der Welt gibt, aber die ist nicht perfekt. In wenigen Fällen kann es vorkommen, dass wir doch ein Gesicht erkennen können. Dann ist es aber wichtig, dass ein Benutzer von Street View dieses Bild runternehmen lassen kann, schnell und unbürokratisch.
Also wo ich meine, hey, kannst du schnell und unbürokratisch runternehmen, ist doch super oder nicht?
Super, du musst doch erst mal darauf kommen, dass das Bild da ist und wo das ist und so weiter.
Ja, wenn es dann auf Reddit ist, wieder nackt auf dem Vorgarten rumspringen.
Ja, meinst du das ernsthaft? Du weißt doch gar nicht, ob du draußen aufgenommen wurdest. Ich komme noch gar nicht auf die Idee nachzugucken, bin ich irgendwo, wo ich vielleicht mal in Berlin oder sonst wo auf der Straße gefilmt wurde, bin ich da aufgenommen worden.
Weißt du, auf wie vielen japanischen Urlaubsfotos du bist, die auf Flickr hochgeladen wurden?
Ja gut, es geht mir auch nicht im Endeffekt nur um diese Privatsphäre vom Gesicht an sich, es geht mir auch allein ums Prinzip, das ich für unnötig halte, dass Google die Straßen von Deutschland und von Berlin hier filmt.
Aber warum nicht?
Jeder der im Urlaub ist, macht Fotos und viele Leute stellen das ins Internet.
Ja gut, das ist für mich noch was anderes als ein Unternehmen.
Was ist dagegen einzuwenden? Ich finde tatsächlich, es gibt durchaus praktische Anwendungen für, ich setze mich jetzt vor meinem Browser und klicke mal, wie so eine Straße aussieht.
Schön, das ist ja schön, dass es praktische Anwendungen gibt. Es gibt bestimmt auch schöne praktische Anwendungen, wenn du mein Gesicht hättest und im Internet damit was machen könntest.
Warte mal, also zwei verschiedene Sachen. Übers Gesicht haben wir schon geredet, das ist sozusagen, das hält sich eher um.
Damit wollte ich dir verdeutlichen, dass es schön ist, dass man vielleicht auch gute Sachen damit machen kann.
Nee, warte, stopp, stopp. Aber was ist dagegen einzuwenden, dass die Straßen und Häuser gezeigt werden?
Na gut, wenn ich ein Haus habe, das da irgendwie vielleicht irgendwo steht halt, dann möchte ich nicht, dass die das finden, zum Beispiel.
Warum?
Ja, warum ist nochmal eine andere Frage. Die Sache ist, dass ich als Hausbesitzer natürlich das Recht habe, zu sagen, nee, ich möchte nicht Leute, dass ihr mein Haus... Weil ich hab vorne an meiner Haustür zum Beispiel ein Pornobild zu hängen.
Tatsächlich ist es in Deutschland so, jeder hat das Recht ein Haus zu fotografieren. Und Google hat es jetzt tatsächlich so eingerichtet, wenn du Hausbesitzer bist oder Bewohner eines Hauses, kannst du hingehen und sogar jetzt vor der Live-Schaltung von Citu sagen, ich möchte nicht, dass er das zeigt. Aber rechtlich gesehen wären sie eigentlich im Recht. Was ich aber viel interessanter finde, ist, warum willst du das nicht?
Also ich bin der Meinung, dass ich kein Paranoia bin, äh, ein Paranoid bin. Wie nennt man es dann? Oder dass ich kein Verschuldungstheoretiker bin, für den du mich jetzt vielleicht so ein bisschen äh, unterschwellig darstellen willst.
Nein, nein. Ich möchte nur von dir eine klare Antwort auf die Frage, warum du nicht willst, dass dein Haus bei Street View auftaucht.
Vielleicht kann ich dir jetzt da gar nicht so eine klare Antwort sofort auf...
Aber eine klare Antwort wäre für mich auch, wenn du sagst, ich fühle mich dabei unwohl.
Na gut, also dann hast du mir ein Argument, sag ich schon mal, vorweggenommen, ja. Das wäre zum Beispiel ein Argument, ja.
Das war genau der Punkt. Also von wegen private Daten schützen, öffentliche Daten nützen, da ist genau so, ja, dass das halt die Abwägung ist. Sind das öffentliche Daten, sind das private Daten, sind das Daten, die schützenswert sind, sind die Daten in der Gesamtheit, wenn man von allen Häusern in Deutschland, die an irgendeiner öffentlichen Straße stehenden Foto hat, sind das dann, ja, ist das, was sich aus der Korrelation dieser Daten ergibt, ist das schützenswerter als Einzelfotos. Da ist eben genau der Punkt, wo man diese Unterscheidung dann irgendwo für sich treffen muss.
Abgesehen davon, dass das gesetzlich erlaubt ist, finde ich es auch, muss ich jetzt sagen, ehrlich gar nicht gut, dass jeder mein Haus fotografieren könnte. Das will ich jetzt von dir zum ersten Mal erfahren, aber ich finde es halt nicht gut.
Das ist dann die nächste Frage, wenn man sich dann weiterhin anguckt, was für Fotos von Leuten im Internet hochgeladen werden. Alles, was man ins Internet stellt, muss man von ausgehen, dass es dort bleibt. Das Internet ist ein, ja, write once, read many medium sozusagen. Ja, ist die Frage, was denn aus der Korrelation entsteht, wenn in Zukunft das Algorithmen gibt, die Gesichter zuverlässig erkennen können. Dann sind die ganzen vorhandenen Daten ja durchaus eine Basis für ganz andere neue Erkenntnisse.
Genau, darüber habe ich nämlich auch schon nachgedacht. Ich bin auch bis jetzt, muss ich sagen, zum Glück sehr vorsichtig gewesen, bzw. hat sich auch einfach nicht ergeben, dass ich so viel reinstelle. Aus diesen Prinzipien, die mich zu diesen anderen Sachen bringen, auch gar nicht bei Studi, bei Dies, Das, bei den ganzen Portalen bin ich überhaupt nicht, obwohl ich jetzt auch viel mit den Rechnern mache und so weiter. Und ich muss auch sagen, das, was du gerade gesagt hast, genau, da hab ich mich immer oft drüber Gedanken. Ich weiß nicht, ob das direkt mit Google zusammenhängt, aber ich denke, die haben bestimmt jetzt auch so einen Algorithmen, dass es Algorithmen gibt, die allein lernfähig sind, heute schon, und die irgendwelche Informationen, die dir total unsichtig anscheinend, wenn du sie als einzelne Informationen nimmst, sammeln und so verwerten, dass da was ganz anderes dabei rauskommt. Also das stimmt mich auf jeden Fall bedenklich so. Und wenn ich sehe, dass die so einen lernfähigen Algorithmen haben, und Google bestimmt auch, und die so eine riesigen Informationsmengen sammeln, dann bin ich da schon skeptisch.
Als Abschluss gleich für dich ein kleiner Tipp, du kannst dir ja einen Stoppschäd an dein Haus kleben.
Ja, ist schon eine gute Idee, aber...
Aber wenn ich das zusammenfasse, ist es dir einfach unwohl bei dem Gedanken daran, dass bestimmte Dinge über dich im Netz zu finden sind, und bei dem Gedanken daran, dass möglicherweise in Zukunft bei den Dingen, die das Netz schon über dich weiß, noch Zusammenhänge hergestellt werden, die man noch gar nicht absehen kann.
Genau, ich hab natürlich auch ein paar Bilder im Netz, bzw. hab auch Kumpels, die dann bei Studi was reinstellen. Aber denen sag ich zum Beispiel, ich weiß auch nicht, ob das das Richtige war, ob es überhaupt ein Fehler war. Ich hab dann einfach zugelassen, ich hab ihnen gesagt, natürlich verknüpft es aber bitte auf keinen Fall mit meinem Namen. Also wenn mein Foto schon drin ist mit dir, wo ich jetzt da irgendwie vielleicht mal ein Bierchen trinke, dann schreib aber nicht dazu. Da gibt es ja teilweise noch Leute, die jedes Gesicht mit einem Namen verlinken.
Okay, das ist dann aber noch eine ganz andere Diskussion. Wir reden hier gerade über Google. David, dir erstmal vielen Dank. Wir haben noch ein paar Anrufer in der Leitung. Als nächstes werden wir mit jemand sprechen, deren Mutter Richterin ist, die irgendwie mit Google Street View zu tun hat. Mit dem Chaos Computer Club, weil letzter Mittwoch im Monat, also Chaos Radio mit Huckel und Nibbler und Markus Richter hier am Moderationsdingens. Und es geht heute um Google und so Daten online speichern. Wir sind gerade bei Google Street View gewesen. Also dieses Ding, wo man halt durch die Straßen cruisen kann, ganz virtuell am Rechner. Und jetzt ist Anna dran. Hallo, Anna. Du oder bzw. deine Mutter hat irgendwie mit Street View zu tun.
Also meine Mutter ist am Verwaltungsgericht. Und ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, warum sie damit zu tun hatte. Aber jedenfalls gucken irgendwie Leute, gucken sich halt Google Street View an und gucken dann, ob irgendjemand da mit einem Gericht drauf verlinkt ist.
Und dann verklagen sie den.
Oder in allen Dingen, dann verklagen sie Google dafür. Und irgendwie kommt da jeden Tag ein Haufen neuer Klagen an, weil es so viele Gesichter sind.
Und ich hab's mir neuerlich auch mal angeguckt.
Und also da sind wirklich viele Gesichter drauf.
Aber wie genau geht das? Google ist doch in Deutschland noch gar nicht live.
Äh, doch. Ich weiß es nicht genau, aber ich glaube, ich hab mal irgendwas. Ist es nicht?
Also, würde mich jetzt überraschen. Ich kann mal jemand gucken.
Das letzte Mal, als ich geguckt hab, gab's das noch nicht. Und ich hab auch erst kürzlich davon gelesen, hier im Spiegel und Tagesspiegel, dass sie da noch heftig am zanken sind.
Auf der Pressekonferenz sagten sie, wir wollen dieses Jahr noch.
Zumindest war das Google Street Views Car in Berlin. Da gab's so eine Seite, wo Leute einen GPS-Tracker unter das Auto gehängt haben und live man mitverfolgen konnte, wo sich dieses Google Street Views noch geht.
Die Autos waren unterwegs, die Bilder gibt es, aber sie ist noch nicht öffentlich. Deswegen würde mich interessieren, wer da verklagt wird.
Also wahrscheinlich wird Google doch verklagt. Irgendwelche Klagen sind da jedenfalls eingegangen.
Und vielleicht, ich weiß es nicht, ich hab wahrscheinlich so, dass ich irgendwie in einem anderen Land geguckt habe bei Street View, weil es gibt es ja jetzt in England, glaube ich.
Also in Europa gibt es das sonst, also Skandinavien ist schon am Start, Frankreich, Großbritannien.
Doch, ich glaube, ich hab mir auch England angeguckt und da sind auch jede Menge Köpfe drauf.
Aber jetzt können ja Leute aus Großbritannien schlecht bei deiner Mutter, die ja in Deutschland Richterin ist.
Ja, ja, wahrscheinlich.
Also wahrscheinlich, keine Ahnung, wer das war.
Also ich weiß es auch nicht, ich dachte, das wär jetzt schon hier in Deutschland, aber falsch gedacht.
Okay, falls du es genauer rausfindest und dann auch drüber reden darfst, sag uns Bescheid.
Ja, und ich glaube, dass sie das, das kann man verklagen, weil die Leute wollen nämlich nicht, dass, also das wird irgendwie verschwommen, weil die Leute nicht wollen, dass die, dass irgendwelche, ihre Arbeitgeber zum Beispiel, sie ihre Posten einmal googeln und dann sehen, wie das Haus aussieht und ob sie jetzt arm oder reich sind und in welchen Verhältnissen sie leben und so. Und deshalb ist es irgendwie, wollen die das nicht.
Und die Daten gibt es aber auch schon zu kaufen. Die Daten gibt es aber auch schon zu kaufen.
Aber dann muss man sie wenigstens noch bezahlen. Okay, Anna, es klingt total interessant, aber es ist ein bisschen schwammig. Nächstes Mal vielleicht. So, Gott, Google scheint die Leute schon zu beschäftigen. Wollen wir weitermachen oder wollt ihr noch kurz mal?
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, dieser Punkt irgendwie, was denn da sozusagen überhaupt gespeichert wird, also dieses Verknüpfen von Daten, was der eine Anrufer auch gemeint hat. Also es gibt halt so eine Reihe von Einzelinformationen da und man weiß gar nicht, ob die jetzt einzeln überhaupt Sinn machen, aber er hat ja befürchtet irgendwie, es besteht dann die Gefahr, die mit Algorithmen und so weiter zu verknüpfen und dann so ein Profil zu erstellen, hatte ich ja auch schon am Anfang gesagt. Und wenn man sich dann halt sozusagen jetzt mal so dieses Verschwörungstheoretiker-Paranoiker-Szenario anguckt, und versucht mal durchzuspielen, was könnten sie denn machen, dann ist es halt so, wir brausen irgendwelche Google-Services und haben ja, wie wir schon gesagt haben, diesen Cookie von Google bekommen. Da steht halt so eine eindeutige Nummer drin. Und für alles, was wir da auf den Google-Rechnern machen, speichern sie sozusagen immer für jeden Request sozusagen unsere IP-Adresse. Diese Nummer aus unserem Cookie. Und was wir halt da genau treiben, also bei der Suche, die Suchwörter, bei Maps, wo hin wir wollen, welche Routen wir planen und so weiter und so fort. Gut, so. Und dann in dem Moment, wo man sich halt zum Beispiel einloggt mit seinem Gmail-Account und so weiter, gibt es dann sozusagen schon mal die Korrelation zwischen deinem Namen, deiner Email-Adresse, deinen Kontakten, deinen Maps, den du gesucht hast, den Suchwörtern, den du gesucht hast, welche Newsfeeds du abonniert hast, und, und, und, und. Und so weiter und so fort. Genau, also die Sache ist halt auch irgendwie, es ging auch kürzlich durch die Medien, dass halt Google auch sozusagen gesagt hat, wir speichern jetzt auch die Suchanfragen von Leuten, die nicht einen Account haben, mit eben genau dieser Cookie-Session. Und das tun sie halt neun Monate unanonymisiert. Und nach, also nach diesem neun, oder im neunten Monat fangen sie halt an, irgendwie drei, vier Zahlen von der IP-Adresse zu anonymisieren. Und nach 18 Monaten anonymisieren sie es vollständig. Und nach dem 18 Monat löschen sie dann wohl auch die Cookie-Informationen, die gesammelten. Also es sind halt sozusagen neun bis 18 Monate liegen dann sozusagen diese ganzen angesammelten Daten, wenn man sich eben vorstellt, tagtäglich Maps gesucht, benutzt, tagtäglich Google Search benutzt, tagtäglich News gelesen, tagtäglich irgendwie in Mailinglisten gepostet und tagtäglich, wer weiß was, noch alles gemacht. Telefongesünd, GPS-Daten, Locations und so weiter. Dann kann man eben mit diesem Profil, sollte es dann irgendwie mal ans Tageslicht kommen, schon ein ziemlich genaues Profil bilden. Wann ist Markus zum Beispiel üblicherweise in Potsdam? Könnten wir jetzt um... Am letzten, so ne Geschichten halt. Und der Eric Schmidt hat ja in diesem einen Interview eben auch gesagt, also nicht nur, dass wenn man Daten nicht in Google haben will, dann soll man sie gar nicht erst machen sozusagen oder online stellen. Aber er hat dann eben auch im Nebensatz noch gesagt, dass eben durch diesen Patriot Act und Vorratsdatenspeicherung sehr wohl eben auch der Staat Zugriff auf diese Daten hat. Gut, jetzt denkt man sich, wenn der Staat irgendwie dann Grund hat oder Grund sieht an die Daten ranzukommen, dann wird das schon alles seine Richtigkeit haben. Genau. Ist halt aber eben auch die Frage, wenn sich die Leute gar nicht bewusst sind, dass überhaupt diese Daten da sind, ja, und so verknüpft werden können, ja, ist das halt aus meiner Sicht...
Aber das hört sich schon mal alles an, also nur unter der Promisse, dass es wegkommt. Also solange alles gut läuft, ist eigentlich alles okay.
Na ja, also wenn der Staat rankommt, ist noch alles okay.
Okay, das wäre schon nochmal diskutabel, aber sozusagen die Gesamtargumentation hört sich an wie... Also das ist vor allem deshalb gefährlich, weil es in die Hände von jemanden kommen könnte, den es eigentlich nichts angeht.
Na eigentlich ist es auch schon bei vorangegangenen Sendungen, die sich um diese Themen gedreht haben mit Social Networks und warum man jetzt nicht unbedingt alle seine Daten und seine Adresse und sein Alter und seine Schulen eingeben sollte, ist halt einfach dieses Datenansammeln an sich problematisch. Denn wo Daten da sind, da gibt es halt dieses Potenzial für Missbrauch. Und früher oder später passiert das halt. Man hat irgendwie so oft schon in den Nachrichten gelesen, dass britische Parlamentsmitarbeiter irgendwelche CDs in Zügen liegen lassen oder dass irgendwelche Webseiten aufgehackt wurden. StudiVZ ohnehin in den Nachrichten.
Mein Google Account ist schon mal gehackt worden. Also einer meiner Google Accounts.
Und dann in dem Moment haben sie einfach mal einmal alles und können dann irgendwie weiter damit verfahren. Also ich meine, es gibt halt...
Aber unter dieser Gefahr stehe ich auch, wenn ich irgendwo anders meinen E-Mail-Account habe.
Es ist schon ein Unterschied, ob du da nur deinen E-Mail-Account hast oder ob da wirklich alle Daten über dein privates Leben zusammenfließen. Das ist ein Unterschied, ob jemand dein E-Mails kennt oder weiß, wer hat sich letzte Woche informiert, Preise, Plasma, Fernseher, hat schon länger keinen Urlaub mehr gemacht, wird wahrscheinlich von den Millionen, der hier beim RBB verdient sich dann doch mal irgendwie. Und er ist jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat in Potsdam und nicht zu Hause. Das ist schon nochmal eine andere Qualität, als er schreibt seiner Mutti.
Okay, ich habe aber, ich twittere deswegen immer an meine Rottweiler zu Hause, damit das so aussieht. Okay, also ich habe jetzt sehr ausführlich erklärt, was passiert, wenn sozusagen alle Daten auf einem Haufen liegen. Und wenn wir jetzt mal mit Julian sprechen, der hat nämlich eine sehr klare Meinung dazu. Hallo Julian. Was hast du jetzt genau gehört? All deine Daten auf einem Haufen, das kann ganz schön gefährlich werden unter Umständen. Was hältst du davon?
Na ja, also jetzt gleichgültig. Ich habe am Anfang gleichgültig gesagt, das ist jetzt nicht ganz so richtig. Aber Fakt ist, dass jeder überlegen sollte, was er für Daten online stellt. Also das ist eigentlich Punkt eins. Jeder muss einfach gucken, was für Daten über sich selbst gibt er Preis und es lässt er halt öffentlich einsehen. Und ja, da muss jeder selber überlegen, was für Daten er online stellt.
Siehst du dann einen qualitativen Unterschied zwischen Daten online stellen und Daten in einer Firma wie Google zum Verarbeiten übergeben? Weil bei Google ist ja das Konzept, dass sie deine privatesten Daten nehmen und dir privat persönlich einen Service dafür anbieten und deine Daten für dich quasi aufbereiten. Der Unterschied ist dann schon nochmal zu, du stellst deine Daten ins Netz und jeder kann sie einsehen. Siehst du da irgendwie einen qualitativen Unterschied? Oder ist das für dich ein und dasselbe?
Nein, definitiv nicht dasselbe. Da ist ein ganz klarer Unterschied. Aber selbst bei Google, ich bin eingeflashter Google Nutzer. Also Google Mail benutze ich, Google jetzt nicht. Also kein Google Account, aber Google Mail halt.
Dann hast du einen Google Account.
Dann hab ich einen Google Account.
Und klickst du immer auf Sign Out, wenn du dann Google browsst und Maps benutzt und so weiter?
Ich browse gar nicht, weil das Ganze über Mail läuft, also über iMap.
Also du meldest dich mit dem Google Account nicht bei Google auf der Seite an?
Aber selbst bei Google Mail kann ich ja selber entscheiden, was für Daten ich angebe. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass ich komplett ausgehorcht werde und meine komplette Adresse angeben muss. Siehe damals glaube ich bei Web.de. Da musste ich mir einen Brief zuschicken lassen und so weiter und fort. Also das war ja noch richtig scharf. Also an der Stelle, wo ich entscheiden musste, bitte geben sie mir meine Adresse. Ich muss meine Adresse eingeben, habe ich schon gesagt, ok danke und tschüss.
Das ist aber schon eine Frage. Also für Google ist ein Persönlichkeitsprofil ein Persönlichkeitsprofil. Ob da jetzt dein eigener Name oder Hans Müller dran steht.
Ja und ich meine, das ist eigentlich dann der wesensichere Punkt, ist eigentlich dieses anonyme Netz. Also das finde ich eigentlich viel schlimmer, dass man die Möglichkeit hat, so viele Profile anzulegen, wie man halt selber, ja.
Aber wenn du immer von der gleichen IP-Adresse kommst und dann eine...
Oder mit dem gleichen Google Cookie?
Oder mit dem gleichen Google Cookie, dann kann halt irgendeine Entität, die dazu befugt ist, halt mal anklopfen und sagen, wir hätten gerne mal den Namen von dem Inhaber dieser IP-Adresse und alles, was ihr dazu wisst.
IP-Adressen sind doch dynamisch. Also IP-Adressen sind doch gar keine eindeutigen...
Deswegen gibt es Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Genau, darum gibt es Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Lass es anders formulieren. Du bist über eine Google Suchanfrage auf die Seite vom BKA mit den meistgesuchten Leuten gekommen. Und die finden das jetzt spannend und wissen gerne, wer hinter dieser Suchanfrage, nach was er sonst noch gesucht hat, und IP-Adressen, um herauszufinden, was für eine physikalische Person gewohnt der Adresse, Stammdaten.
Was ich noch viel spannender finde, ist, du hast erzählt, irgendwie bei Mail hast du falsche Daten angegeben, aber deine Mails laufen ja darüber. Die werden ja auch alle von Google gelesen.
Genau, was für mehr bekommst du da?
Ist das privat?
Das ist weitgehend privat, aber Sachen, die halt, ich sag mal, über, also Bankdaten zum Beispiel werde ich definitiv nicht über meine Mails laufen lassen.
Aber privat, also irgendwie Liebesbriefe, Verabredungen?
Ja, okay, genau. Genau sowas, unter anderem.
Und das ist dir dann zu sagen, aber auch egal?
Naja, ich weiß nicht, ich find das nicht so heiß. Gut, ich meine, das hängt natürlich auch mit meiner, ich hab auch irgendwie das Gefühl, dass der Durchschnittsbürger jetzt nicht sonderlich interessant ist für den Missbrauch von Daten. So, das ist es halt. Natürlich gibt es Personen, die sicherlich potentielle, potentiell googlebare Personen sind, die auch interessante Daten liefern könnten. Aber das ist nicht der Durchschnittsbürger irgendwie. Und ich meine, in dem Fall, wo eine Person halt googlebar ist und diese Daten, die ja zur Verfügung stellt, negativ verwendet werden können, dann sollte er auch unter Umständen googlebar sein, oder nicht?
Interessante Frage. Sollte man googlebar sein?
Naja, wie gesagt, ich meine, sobald man googlebar ist, hat man selber persönlich Daten ins Netz gestellt. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass Google jetzt meine Daten online präsentiert.
Naja, wenn du googlebar bist, heißt das nur, dass irgendjemand Daten über dich ins Netz gestellt hat. Ob du das bist oder jemand anders, ist ja erstmal...
Das ist richtig, klar. Ähm, also jetzt, ähm... Anders, wir waren vorhin bei Street View, diese Geschichte. Da hat meine Freundin einen sehr interessanten Aspekt ins Spiel gebracht, und zwar die Tatsache, dass Google eher in der Pflicht sein sollte, halt die Erlaubnis einzuholen.
Sind die auch gefragt worden auf der Pressekonferenz? Haben sie gesagt, wäre dann nicht mehr bezahlbar?
Das ist ja richtig. Und ich meine, das ist halt wirklich auch dieser potenzielle Nutzen, den man davon hat. Man muss ja im Prinzip bei solchen Vorgängen sich immer fragen, wie groß ist der positive potenzielle Nutzen einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung und der potenzielle negativer Auswirkung.
Vorratsdatenspeicherung hat erstmal nichts mit Google zu tun. Also das kommt irgendwo zusammen, aber es ist nicht sozusagen unbedingt eine Googelsache.
Ja, okay, das ist nur Teil der ganzen Geschichte im Prinzip. Deswegen, also ich meine, ja, Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist...
Auch doof. Oh, kann man gar nicht mehr so richtig schön anonym sein.
Das zerfasert sich jetzt hier zunehmend. Du wirst aber weiter Google nutzen.
Ich werde weiter Google nutzen, alleine wegen der Master Funktionalität, Stichwort IMAP, kostenfrei. Die Suchmaschine ist einfach wirklich gut programmiert.
Und du wirst sozusagen weiter darauf achten, dass nichts zu persönliches über dich ins Netz kommt und gehst davon aus, dass du selber als Person jetzt erst mal nicht so interessant bist, dass irgendwas mit deinen Daten angestellt wird?
Ja, gut, das prinzipiell, ja.
Okay, so grob zusammengefasst. Julian, vielen Dank.
Bitte, bitte.
So, dann gehen wir mal sozusagen, ich denke, direkt zur Gegenposition über und die kommt von Holger. Hallo Holger.
Ja, hallo.
Hast du auch ein E-Mail-Konto bei Google?
Nee, hab ich nicht.
Warum nicht?
Weil ich ein anderes E-Mail-Konto hab, was für mich besser funktioniert.
Okay, da hast du also sagen, nicht gegen Google entschieden wirst, sondern hast einfach was, was besser ist.
Genau.
Und so sonst so, Google?
Also ich nutze die Suchmaschine viel und gerne und Google Earth nutze ich auch sehr gerne und freue mich schon sehr auf das Streetview. Ja, und kann diese ganze Paranoia also überhaupt nicht im Allergensten nachvollziehen. Und ja, finde man kann sehr viel Zeit damit vergeuden, sich Gedanken darüber zu machen, was im allerschlimmsten Fall mit den Daten passieren könnte. Aber ich glaube, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit so gering ist, dass die Mühe eigentlich nicht lohnt. Und ich finde es zum einen sehr ehrenwert, dass ihr darüber aufklärt und so weiter. Aber jedes Mal, wenn ich mal beim Chaosradio einhöre, dann geht es immer um diese Daten, was könnte passieren. Und das ist wirklich wie bei so Verschwörungstheoretikern, die nie konkret was sagen, sondern immer nur, ja, man weiß ja nicht, und wir sagen ja nicht, aber man könnte allein die Tatsache, und dann werden da Fantasiekonstrukte erzeugt, also auch von der Hörer, und solche Hörer generiert er ja, der mit dem Streetview da seine Porno-Seite ans Haus klebt, aber auf gar keinen Fall will, dass irgendwer das sieht. Also ich weiß gar nicht, wie viel Fantasie ich ausbringen müsste, um mir die schlimmstmögliche Konsequenz vorzustellen, die passieren könnte, wenn man mein Gesicht da... Also ich mein, ich geh doch auch so über die Straße. Was soll denn da sein? Mein Gott, dann sieht man halt dein Gesicht oder dein Autokennzeichen. Also ich fahr ja auch nicht mehr U-Bahn, weil da die Bahnhöfe mit Kameras überwacht werden.
Gibst du mir dann vielleicht dein privates Adressbuch? Ich würde dann darauf aufpassen, wenn du mal Kontakte davon brauchst, gebe ich sie dir auch nicht, verspreche dir auch, keinem anderen die zu geben.
Na ja, man kann ja schon bewusst mit dem Internet umgehen. Also ich gebe zum Beispiel ungern meine E-Mail-Adresse raus, aber mehr, weil ich keinen Bock habe, irgendwelche Spams zu bekommen. Klar, ich verstehe auch Jugendliche nicht, die irgendwie besoffene Fotos irgendwo hinstellen, wo sie nicht wissen, wo es hingeht. Aber jetzt bei jeder Suchanfrage die Stelle zu überlegen, ach jetzt weiß aber einer, sich mich über Plasmas Fernseher interessiere und so, also da macht man sich doch verrückt, oder?
Ja klar, ne also, es soll, sind halt negative Beispiele.
Ist aber schon die Frage, also, würdest du Google dein Adressbuch anvertrauen, zum Beispiel? Wenn du jetzt der Meinung bist, dass die schon mit den Daten gut umgehen werden, dass sich dafür keiner interessiert, über deine privaten Daten, hättest du da ein gutes Gefühl dabei, oder hast du das?
Also ein gutes Gefühl hätte ich glaube ich grundsätzlich nicht, aber, also das ist wie gesagt, wie bei so Verschwungstheoretikern, so lange ich das Gegenteil nicht beweisen kann, ist es irgendwie, ja, weiß ich nicht.
Würde dich, also warum hast du da ein schlechtes Gefühl, oder würde dich das schlechte Gefühl davon abhalten, das zu tun, wenn das für dich angenehm wäre und praktisch, wenn du irgendwie zwischen deinem Telefon, deinem E-Mail klarend und was weiß ich auch immer, deine Adressen synchronisieren könntest, würde dich das schlechte Gefühl davon abhalten, das zu tun, oder?
Vielleicht weil ich zu oft Chaos Radio höre und das. Nee, war ja gut, weiß ich nicht, jetzt so private, aber mit E-Mails ist ja genauso. Also ein Freund von mir meinte, also ich kenn mich ja nicht so gut mit Computern außer, der meinte also, schreib niemals in der E-Mail was, von dem du nicht willst, dass du irgendjemand anders liest, außer dem, dem du die E-Mail schreibst, weil das ist völlig naiv zu glauben, dass das irgendwie geheim bleibt. Und das mach ich natürlich auch nicht. Also klar, ein gewisses Bewusstsein muss man natürlich schon haben, aber ich hab zum Beispiel einen Freund, der kauft grundsätzlich niemals mit einer EC-Karte ein, weil dann könnte ja einer sehen, dass er bei all die 12, 30 Euro ausgegeben hat. Und ich finde, da macht man sich wirklich unnötig das Leben schwer.
Wo ist denn die Grenze bei dir? Also was würdest du sagen, wo sagst du, na, das müsste jetzt aber nicht sein. Also ich finde Street View dann ein schönes Beispiel, weil es gibt ja die ganze Diskussion kam damals auf, glaube ich, weil in den USA jemand auf Street View zu sehen wäre, der aus einem Pornoladen gerade kommt. Könnte dir ja auch passieren, theoretisch. Wäre das noch okay?
Da würde ich sagen, habe ich halt einfach Pech gehabt. Also das kann mir auch passieren, dass ich aus einem Pornoladen komme und dann kommt ein Bekannter von mir vorbei. Also dann muss ich halt eine Maske aufsetzen, wenn ich da so eine Panik vor hab. Aber klar, das ist dann natürlich ärgerlich in dem Fall. Aber wenn man, ich meine, in 99, 9% der Fälle kommt man ja nicht aus einem Pornoladen, sondern geht gerade irgendwo lang. Und auch dieses Beispiel, da wird mein Haus gefilmt. Ja, meine Güte, dein Haus steht doch öffentlich in der Straße. Das sehen auch Leute, die einfach nur so vorbeigehen. Was soll sich denn irgendjemand Schlimmes dabei denken, wenn er dein Haus irgendwie sieht? Und das wollte ich auch noch sagen, dass diese Massen an Daten, also klar weiß man nicht, was irgendwann in 20 Jahren vielleicht damit mal gemacht wird oder wer das in die Hände bekommt und so. Aber das hat man doch an der DDR gesehen, dass dieses inflationäre Sammeln von Daten, also von so völlig nutzlosen Daten, ja doch eher kontraproduktiv ist. Und solange ich nichts mache, wo ich, ich meine, wir sind ja nicht alle irgendwie illegal unterwegs, dass man, weiß ich nicht, dass man wirklich Sachen hat, wo man berechtigte Gründe hat, dass man das nicht möchte, dass das Leute erfahren, sondern das meiste ist so banal, dass ich auch glaube, da überschätzt man sich selbst, wenn man denkt, dass sich so viele Leute dafür interessieren.
Ok, kleines Beispiel.
Auch wenn es so lang gesammelt wird, also wenn in drei Jahren einer immer noch weiß, dass ich mich vor drei Jahren mal für den Plasma-Bildschirm interessiert hab, dann kann er das ja gerne aufheben und sich damit beschäftigen, aber ich glaube, das bringt ihm dann jetzt in sich gar nicht viel.
Ich möchte mal ein kleines Beispiel von wegen Daten, wie man sie nutzen kann. Das ist jetzt erst neulich rausgekommen von Forschern aus Wien, glaube ich. Die haben sich einfach mal, die haben alle öffentlich verfügbaren Informationen aus sozialen Netzwerken gesammelt. Also Dinge, die man einfach sehen kann, wenn man nichts Besonderes macht, wenn man sich einfach das soziale Netzwerk anguckt. Und konnten dann aufgrund der Mitgliedschaft in verschiedenen Gruppen in sozialen Netzwerken sagen, welche Leute gerade am Rechner sitzen. Das wäre vor einem Jahr noch undenkbar gewesen, dass sowas geht. Mittlerweile funktioniert es.
Das ist eben genau der Punkt, von dem ich schon gesagt habe, dass man aus dem Datenwust gar nicht so viel raus. Das hat sich eben wirklich geändert. Das ist das Konzept von Google im Prinzip aus einer Masse an Daten. Google hat damit angefangen, das Internet anzuschauen. Das Internet ist einfach mal eine Masse aus Daten, die einfach unübersichtlich sind, da eine Ordnung drin zu finden. Und wenn jemand mit einem massiven Überschuss an Daten umgehen kann und da genau das Richtige rausfinden kann, nach dem man sucht, dann ist es Google. Das ist keine 20 Jahre entfernt, sondern das ist schon relativ nahe. Das ist schon dann die Frage, die man für sich persönlich beantworten muss. Wie viel von meinen Daten bin ich bereit, für welchen Komfort herzugeben? Und was ist mir jetzt vielleicht doch zu privat für Google? Und da muss, glaube ich, jeder für sich selber seinen Punkt finden, wo er sich selbst noch wohlfühlt mit den Daten, die er hergibt und mit der Gegenleistung, die er bekommt. Wie du jetzt schon sagst, es ist egal, wenn jemand ein Foto von dir macht, wo du rumläufst, dann ist das so. Andere Leute sind da geheimniskrämerischer drauf. Es ist wichtig, nicht zu vergessen, dass wirklich der Sinn aus den Daten aus der Analyse entsteht.
Das seh ich natürlich ganz genau so. Das muss jeder für sich selbst entscheiden. Aber ich glaube, dass viele Leute sich selber da gar nicht mehr kontrollieren, sondern in diesen Dingen drin sind. Um Gottes Willen meine Daten, die darf ich nicht bekannt geben. Und sich gar nicht mal diesen Worst Case überhaupt nur mal eine Minute ausmalen. Was wäre denn im schlimmsten Fall? Das Beispiel hat mich auch nicht so beeindruckt. Also dann wissen sie halt, dass ich gerade am Computer sitze. Also die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist ja nicht so gering. Also meine Güte, wo ist das Problem für mich?
Nee, nee, da geht es nicht nur darum, dass du da am Computer sitzt. Dann geht es darum, die wissen, wer gerade was am Rechner macht und wer das ist. Also lässt sich quasi wieder welche Seiten besucht er gerade. Also klar, ein plastisches Beispiel wieder, wenn jemand bei Facebook Mitglied in der Gruppe Pornostars finde ich geil und bei Xing Mitglied in der Gruppe Geschäftsführer von großen Firmen ist, dann kann man da vielleicht schon Informationen rausziehen, die wieder interessant sind. Aber ist natürlich auch, wie du das sagst, natürlich so ein Worst-Case-Szenario, klar.
Genau, es soll hier eigentlich auch gar nicht darum gehen, dass wir jetzt so die Paranoia-Schiene fahren. Also ist klar, hier E-Mail in dem Moment, wo du eine Mail verschickst und sei deinen Mailserver noch so sicher. In dem Moment, wo das in einem Gmail-Konto oder sonst wo landet, ist die halt public. Also man muss sich jetzt gar nicht der Illusion hergeben, dass man jetzt irgendwie noch anonym sein kann so richtig. Und irgendwie jetzt der anonyme Mensch sich da noch irgendwie durchs Netz bewegen kann. Wie gesagt, es geht eben eher um das Bewusstsein. Was mache ich da, was gebe ich da ab? Und was kann da die Folge draus sein? Und hier dieses mit diesem, ist ja nicht illegal usw. Das ist halt auch immer so ein beliebtes Argument. Es ist jetzt vielleicht gerade nicht illegal. Und damals, als wir mal eine Volkszählung gemacht haben, war das auch überhaupt nicht illegal. Aber zum Beispiel Jude zu sein, irgendwann ändert sich ein Gesetz. Und dann kann man halt auf so ein Datenwerk zugreifen und mal rausfinden, wer denn jetzt gerade plötzlich auf einmal illegal ist.
Nein, das Daten auch illegal genutze ich bin ja nicht naiv.
Das glaube ich sicher auch, klar.
Stalker, auch noch so ein Stichwort.
Man kann sich schnell das Leben schwer machen. Also man kann auch sagen, über alles Strahlung, ich gehe nicht mehr aus der Wohnung, ich benutze kein Handy mehr. Also das ist halt irgendwie auch Fortschritt. Street View ist doch super, ich finde das super cool, wenn ich mir da einfach mehr Straßen angucken kann. Und die Gefahr des Porno Bildes, um darauf zurückzukommen, also im Haus klebt es, dass dann auch einer sieht. Wenn man sich so ein Bild hinklebt, will man doch eigentlich aus, so wie man sieht. Die Gefahr würde ich dann in Kauf nehmen.
Also mal zusammengefasst, sagst du schon auch, man soll schon gucken, was man über sich ins Netz stellt?
Definitiv.
Aber du hast irgendwie keine Angst davor, mit den Daten, die du entschlossen hast, ins Netz zu stellen, ist es dann auch okay, dass die verarbeitet werden?
Exakt. Und wie gesagt, ich glaube, das ist halt so ein Selbstläufer, je öfter man drüber redet und so, desto panischer wird man und ist dann nicht mehr so rational in dem Gedanken, was ist tatsächlich die konkrete Gefahr? Oder ist es mehr so ein Reflex, oh Gott, Daten, Panik, gefährlich, sammeln und so weiter. Also das ist so ein Ding, wo ich einfach denke, da muss man immer mal sich selber nochmal erden und überlegen, was ist denn jetzt, wie gesagt, wirklich das Schlimmste, was da tatsächlich passieren kann?
Bis ein selber mal der Gmail-Account gehackt wird und in seinem Namen Spam, Viagra-Spam an alle seine Geschäftsfahler verschickt wird.
Das ist noch keinem, der dir anwesenden passiert.
Das kann es natürlich sein. Wenn einem wirklich mal so was passiert ist, dann würde ich wahrscheinlich auch nochmal ganz anders drüber denken. Aber das kann ich mir ja dann Gedanken drüber machen. Aber da muss ich jetzt nicht vorher Panik schieben und mich dadurch selber erden.
So lange alles gut ist, erst mal weitermachen, ja?
Schönes Schlussstatement.
Ja, dank euch.
Tschüss. Finden wir denn vielleicht noch einen Anrufer, genau eben mit so einem Missbrauchsszenarien-Account gehackt und Schindluder mitbetrieben, Stalker, Ex-Freunde und so weiter. Also ich mein, das ist halt wahrscheinlich so das Realste, was so auch gar nicht so unhäufig passiert und das, ja.
Also ihr habt ja mal gehört, wenn ihr schon mal irgendwie gehackt worden seid oder euch die Identität geklaut wurde oder euch irgendjemand gestalkert mit Informationen aus dem Netz, dann...
Jetzt anrufen!
Der hat gar kein Problem, glaube ich, oder? Toni?
Du hast keine Probleme.
Nee, also ich habe mit dem Ganzen auch absolut gar kein Problem, weil ich bin ganz normaler Internetnutzer, habe ein Google-Handy und allen drum und dran und habe nie Probleme damit gehabt und finde es total Quatsch, jetzt hier dieses Street-View so da schlecht zu machen und einen...
Das ist ja nicht nur Street-Views, aber wenn du schon gesagt hast, du hast ein Google-Handy, synchronisierst du deine Kontakte mit Google? Na klar. Wurdest du, wie Hucke vorhin schon vorgeschlagen hat, die Kontakte auch ihm anvertrauen wollen, wenn er dir verspricht, dass er die Kontakte, dass er da gut drauf aufpasst und wenn du mal irgendwie eine Telefonnummer nachschlagen möchtest, die er dir nennt?
Nee, also ich gebe jetzt nicht irgendjemanden jetzt hier irgendwelche Kontakte, weil die sind natürlich für die privat, aber...
Ich habe auch eine Algebäe.
Letztendlich ist ja auch kein Unterschied zum Telefonbuch früher. Da stand ja auch für jede Adresse zu jeder Telefonnummer zu jedem Namen.
Ja gut, aber da stand eine Name und eine Telefonnummer drin und nicht die Person kennt dieses Set an 100 Leuten. So sind eben seine Kontakte.
Also wir kommen jetzt mal zu einer wirklich wichtigen Frage des Abends. Und die ist, was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen Huckel und Google? Und das klären wir nach den Nachrichten mit Vertrauen Verkehr.
Robbie Williams, Yandilay, Savian Aldo, Gossip und Rihanna live.
Kein Wunder, dass die Tickets für den Echo in Berlin innerhalb von 7 Minuten weg waren. Aber Fritz, wäre nicht Fritz, wenn wir nicht doch ordentlich Tickets für euch gebunkert hätten?
Jetzt präsentiert die Echo Verleihung 2010 in Berlin.
Mit Rihanna, Sadie Naidoo, Yandilay, Gossip und Robbie Williams.
Und das sind längst noch nicht alle. Und wir sind nicht nur live mit dem Fritz Echo Radio dabei, sondern haben auch jede Menge aller allerletzte Tickets. Nur für euch und nur zu gewinnen.
Ab Montagmorgen.
Einfach gut Fritz hören.
Fritzie.
Der Echo 2010 in Berlin. Donnerstag 4. März. Live im ersten deutschen Fernsehen.
Und im letzten deutschen Radio.
Und das hört man.
Um kurz vor halb zwölf.
Nachrichten.
Mit Martin Schneider.
In Brandenburg können Schüler aus sozial schwachen Familien in Zukunft kostenlos zur Schule und wieder nach Hause fahren. Der Landtag stimmte heute einen entsprechenden Antrag der Fraktionen von SPD und Linkspartei zu. Zur Begründung hieß es, Kinder aus Familien, die Sozialleistungen beziehen, müssten die gleichen schulischen Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten haben wie alle übrigen Kinder. Die FDP wollte, dass alle Schüler kostenlos fahren können. Das wurde aber abgelehnt. Der Führerschein mit 17 soll zur Regel werden. Bis zum Ende des Jahres soll das gesetzlich umgesetzt werden. Das kündigte Bundesverkehrsminister Ramsauer an. Er sagte, das begleitende Fahren bringe mehr Sicherheit für junge Fahranfänger. Als erstes Bundesland hatte im Jahr 2004 Niedersachsen den Führerschein mit 17 eingeführt. Dabei dürfen junge Fahranfänger, bis sie 18 sind, nur in Begleitung eines Erwachsenen ans Steuer. Für junge Berliner ist es heute offenbar schwieriger, einen Ausbildungsplatz oder einen Job zu finden als noch vor 20 oder 30 Jahren. Das kam bei einer Umfrage unter 1000 Berlinern raus. Die Mehrheit der Befragten ist der Meinung, dass sich die Politik noch zu wenig für die Schulabgänger einsetzt und dass die Berliner Unternehmen zu wenige Ausbildungsplätze anbieten. Laut der Umfrage sind vor allem gute Deutschkenntnisse wichtig, um bei der Jobsuche erfolgreich zu sein. In der zweiten Fußballbundesliga hat Union Berlin am Abend ein Auswärtsspiel bei Hansa Rostock gehabt. Das Spiel endete 0 zu 0 unentschieden. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Neuropin und Angermünde haben wir 0 Grad. 1 Grad sind es in Potsdam, Frankfurt und Wittenberge, in Cottbus 2 und in Berlin zwischen 1 und 2 Grad. Nachts ist es wolkig, mit etwas Regen. Im Morgen gibt es vereinzelt noch Schnee. Die Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen plus 2 und minus 1 Grad. Morgen ist auch wieder Tauwetter angesagt mit Temperaturen zwischen 7 und 11 Grad. Und ab und zu kann es etwas regnen oder Nieseregen. Davos geht euch eine gute Fahrt, es ist nämlich alles frei.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 101, 5? Dann Fritz in Frankfurt Oder.
Heute Chaos Radio mit Huckel und Liebler vom Chaos Computer Club und mir, Markus Richter. Und es geht heute um... Diggins, was ist der heißt?
Google-Hupf.
Google-Hupf, genau. Und wir haben jetzt schon die ganze Zeit darüber geredet, ob Google vielleicht gefährlich ist, dass die ziemlich viele Daten um uns haben und ich würde jetzt die letzte halbe Stunde gerne auch noch mal ein bisschen dazu nutzen, um über die möglichen Alternativen zu reden und überhaupt darüber zu reden, ob es überhaupt Alternativen gibt oder ob man sich einfach nur heutzutage noch aussuchen kann, wo man jetzt seine Daten alle sammeln lässt.
Aber wenn ihr zum Beispiel gar keine Anrufe und so von Missbrauchsfällen berichtet und so weiter, dann ist ja auch vielleicht einfach alles gut.
Das stimmt. Das stimmt. Genau. Das hat mir vorhin schon gesagt. Also wenn ihr missbraucht worden seid durch euren Google oder was auch immer Account, dann jetzt anrufen. Jetzt haben wir den Sven dran, der meint, wir hätten was ganz Wichtiges vergessen.
Ja, und zwar schütten wir alle über Google Street View und genau wie wir damals schon geschützt haben über Google Maps und mit der Satelliten Ansicht, was ich auch noch gar nicht gehört habe, über Microsoft Bing die Maps, die wir dort anbieten, die sind ja teilweise auch noch ein bisschen umfangreicher als die ganzen Google Maps Geschichten.
Zeig dich mal fest, sitzt du gut? Da gab es neulich so eine Präsentation von Microsoft, dass sie an der Technologie arbeiten, die Livestreaming-Daten mit einbinden kann. Also da wurde eine Bilderkennung, eine Mustererkennung durchgeführt, kann man mit einer Kamera, einem Mobiltelefon zum Beispiel bestimmte Gegenfilme durch das GPS, wurde festgestellt, wo sich der Mensch ungefähr befindet und über die Ähnlichkeit zu bereits vorhandenen Bildern, die schon mal aufgezeichnet wurden, wird dann das jeweilige Video-Bild in das Bild, was man da schon gespeichert hat, eingeblendet. Du hast da so ein Live-Video-Fenster, was dir die Daten anzeigt, die eben gerade diese Kamera aufnimmt, in der passenden Umgebung. Also da ist quasi so ein Fenster in die Realität, was in Echtzeit aktualisiert wird. Gibt es auf ted.com, kann man sich mal angucken, wie so die Zukunfts-Terror-Vision aussieht, was so Daten von öffentlichen Plätzen aussehen.
Es geht ja an der Stelle dann auch weiter. Microsoft zeigt da jetzt gerade sozusagen in dieser Demo, wo es hingeht in den nächsten Evolutionenstufen. Dann haben wir auch alle im iPhoto oder im Picase so eine automatische Gesichtserkennung drin, um unsere Freunde gleich automatisch auf den Fotos zu sortieren. Auch total denkbar, dass das dann einfach auch direkt sozusagen im Streetview vorbei scrollen, ach guck mal, hier ist Tante Erna, mit integriert wird und so weiter. Also klar, das bleibt natürlich auch nicht stehen. Also der Ausblick nach vorne, also das war jetzt sozusagen bis hier in der Momentaufnahme und natürlich, das geht alles noch viel weiter.
Ich meine, wenn man sich, ich weiß ja nicht, den Film Google Epic 2015 kennt ja auf jeden Fall jeder von euch.
Okay, aber für alle, die es nicht kennen, was ist das?
Google Epic ist ein Film, der wurde gemacht 2004, wenn mich recht alles erinnert. Da ging es damals rum, da hatte Google gerade Keyhole gekauft, glaube ich, um die ganzen Bilder zu machen und da wurde so ein bisschen gesponnen, was passiert noch bis 2015 so ungefähr mit der ganzen Entwicklung Google und Co. Und wenn man sich den Film heute mal anschaut und berücksichtigt, dass der von 2004 ist, dann ist schon sehr erschreckend viel davon genau so umgesetzt worden. Also gerade wenn ich mir jetzt Google mit dem mit Latitude zum Beispiel angucke, da wurde damals auch gesponnen, man kann unterwegs seinen Podcast selber schicken, die Freunde sehen halt per GPS, wo man gerade ist und ist halt genauso eingebunden, also so wie Basket zum Beispiel von Google gestartet ist. Also genauso hat man das 2004 ungefähr vorhergesagt und da hat sich den Film das erste Mal 2006 oder so gesehen, da habe ich gesagt, naja, das ist ganz schön gruselig. Wenn man sowas aber zurückklicken sieht, also gibt es ja überall, Google auch bei YouTube zu finden, also Google Epic 2015 ist ein sehr interessantes Film. Also man hat so recht gesponnen, was passiert wenn und genau, wo es eigentlich auch passt zu kommen.
Und was ist deine Konsequenz daraus?
Meine Konsequenz ist sowieso, jeder sollte eigentlich aufpassen, was er selbst preisgibt. Also so wie der, ich weiß jetzt nicht wer hat das gesagt, wenn du nicht willst, dass etwas rauskommt, tu es nicht. Also ich würde auch sagen, wenn du nicht willst, dass etwas im Internet präsentiert wird, dann schickst du das gar nicht dahin. Wenn man sich teilweise Leute anschaut, was sie bei Facebook alles posten.
Aber da sind wir uns ja einig, da wird ja kaum noch eigentlich drüber diskutiert. Mit Tag gibt es auch da Leute, die sind anderer Meinung, aber es geht ja hier eher um die Dinge, die das Netz über dich weiß, einfach weil du da drin unterwegs bist.
Ja klar, man kann es dann irgendwann, also es wird mit der Zeit sicherlich immer schwerer selbst zu bestimmen, wie viele Daten man rausgibt. Also alleine schon, wie gesagt, wenn man jetzt eine alternative Suchmaschine haben will, die nicht die IP speichert oder jetzt halt nicht den Suchverlauf kontrolliert, für den normalen Nutzer halt relativ schwer, sag ich mal, an solchen Sachen ranzukommen. Klar, das wird halt immer schwieriger, darüber noch Herr über seine eigenen Daten zu werden. Aber das können wir glaube ich so richtig gar nicht gegen machen, gegen diese Entwicklung. Weil die Leute, die darüber schimpfen, andersrum, aber auch die sind, die das alles am meisten nutzen, weil sie dieses ganze Angebot, was es im Internet gibt. Und man sollte echt vielleicht so in der Schule, in den Schulen heute schon anfangen, so eine Art...
Medienkompetenz.
Ja, so Medienkompetenz zu schaffen, damit die Schüler echt, ich meine gerade die Schüler von heute, wenn man sich die anschaut an den Schulen, ins Film, so ein Handyvideo, laden das hoch und wissen eigentlich gar nicht, was sie damit tun. Also so wie jetzt die Google Chefs da verklagt wurden oder jetzt auch verurteilt wurden, wegen diesem einen Video, das hätten sich die, die das gefilmt haben, auch niemals ausgerechnet. Dass da irgendwelche Leute für verklagt werden, dass die ein Video hochladen, muss halt irgendjemanden da drangsalieren.
Also es ist halt irgendwie, es fehlt auf jeden Fall bei der jungen Generation, so scheint es zumindest, aber wie sehen Sie eben so das Bewusstsein, dass es eben nicht den digitalen Aktenvernichter gibt, so wie bei der Bundeswehr oder bei irgendwelchen Spendenaffären oder sonst was, wo man dann, ups, mir ist gerade so ein Aktenordner in den Aktenvernichter gefallen, können wir leider nichts mehr machen, sondern dass irgendwie das, was sie jetzt so mit 12, 13, 14 da ins Netz pumpen, einfach noch ihr ganzes Leben da drin stehen wird und auf ewig sozusagen verfügbar ist.
Du meinst also, dass sie Transparenz schaffen, eine Lösung für diverse politische Vorgänge, die eher im Dunkeln stattfinden, Google Documents werden?
Super. Also Sven, ich werde dich jetzt schonmal verabschieden, weil es ist ja quasi 20 Minuten vor 12 und die Leitungen sind noch voll.
Genau.
Ich habe schon einen wichtigen Punkt angesprochen, also es ist nicht nur Google, die damit kommen, sondern der Trend geht allgemein dazu, dass andere Firmen, also das generelle Firmen im Internet, die Verarbeitung der Daten anbieten, dass man seine Dokumente hochladen und bearbeiten kann, von überall aus das Konzept, was dahintersteckt ist, den Benutzern einfach Convenience anzubieten. Das ist einfach furchtbar praktisch, Dinge im Web zu haben, von überall auf seinen Account, auf einem Server, der bei einer Firma steht, zugreifen zu können und da an seine Dokumente zu können. Es gibt heutzutage immer mehr Firmen, die teilweise internste Dokumente in solchen Diensten nutzen, weil eben die Optionen...
Genau, ich habe hier mal unseren Geschäftsplan und irgendwie kannst du nochmal drüber gucken. Ich habe das immer gerade in Google Spreadsheets hochgeladen. Hier ist der URL.
Gab es eigentlich schon mal irgendwie, wo das rausgekommen ist? Also Gauss? Gibt es eigentlich Google Gauss tatsächlich?
Also es gibt bestimmt Blue Pass, also so aus Versehen mal ins falsche Chatfenster gepastet und so. Also das kann ja immer passieren.
Aber das kann ja quasi auch verschicken und dann falsche E-Mail-Adresse. Aber gab es tatsächlich, also gab es tatsächlich, ist auch eine Frage im Wiki zur Sendung, gab es tatsächlich schon mal eine richtige Katastrophe mit Google-Daten?
Ja, das wollen wir wissen.
Okay, anscheinend.
Also mir ist auf jeden Fall kein riesiger Fall bekannt. Was haben wir denn hier sonst noch in meiner Leitung?
Ja, hallo?
Du nutzt Google ja oder nein?
Ja.
Nämlich was?
Eigentlich nur die Suche über Google. Also Stichwörter oder ähnliche Sachen.
Warum nicht noch anderes Zeug?
Na, weil ich auch der Meinung bin, dass das alles zu undurchsichtig ist. Was mit meinen Daten passiert, wo die hingehen, wie die gespeichert werden.
Also das kann man selber persönlich nie nachvollziehen.
Aber warum hast du ein Problem damit?
Na, ähm, ja ein Problem damit. Also im Großen und Ganzen habe ich damit eigentlich kein Problem. Also so hat es Vorteile oder es hat auch Nachteile, wie schon gesagt wurde.
Alles hat so seine Vor-
Genau, erotische Bilder zum Beispiel, die man dann sehen könnte. Wenn ich so ein Bild raushänge, muss ich davon ausgehen, dass das Leute, die vorbeigehen, das sehen wird.
Das ist ganz klar.
Wie zum Beispiel habe ich eben gerade zu einem Kollegen schon gesagt, Weihnachten, ich hänge Weihnachtsbeleuchtung raus, damit es die ganze Welt sieht oder die Leute, die vorbeigehen und sich daran erfreuen. Und wenn jetzt Google Feedview zum Beispiel, da hat zu der Zeit gerade mein Haus so viel Normat, freue ich mich natürlich übelst darüber. Aber andererseits kann man das auch negativ nutzen, wie jetzt zum Beispiel, sag ich mal, jetzt Verbrecher oder so was, oder Diebe oder so.
Ja gut, aber das ist, wie sie sagen, finde ich auch eins der eher schwammigeren Argumente, weil wenn ich irgendwo einbreche mit Verlaub, dann fahre ich hin und mache Hochglanzaufnahmen, damit ich genau weiß, welche Türschlösser die haben und so.
Ja, richtig, richtig, aber da steckt ja dann wieder Arbeit hinter. Also ich muss mich ins Auto setzen, muss da und da hinfahren, muss irgendwelche Akquise betreiben und so, setze ich mich in Sicherheit an Rechner.
Heißt das, dass du am liebsten hättest, dass Google möglichst gar nicht über uns speichert?
Naja, oder wie halt schon meine Vorredner gesagt haben, dass sie wenigstens nachfragen. Und wenn es denen dann halt zu teuer ist, naja, dann wird sie gut haltig machen.
Alles klar, Martin sagt, Google soll nur die Sachen speichern, die wirklich frei geben werden. Das finde ich ja auch so ein Ärgerlich, so ein Ärgernis bei jedem neuen Dienst, den Google eigentlich macht. Sagen, dass sie immer dieses, es gibt dieses Opt-in und Opt-out und eigentlich schalten sie immer erstmal alles frei. Könntet ihr nicht mal was machen?
Muss man sich aber auch vor Augen führen. Google führt zu Produkten ja nicht für 1, 2, 3 User ein, sondern die machen das gleich für Millionen von Nutzern. Das ist ein Massenbetrieb und viele Leute lassen das auf Standardeinstellungen. Das ist für Google ganz einfach am praktischsten und augenscheinlich für die Nutzer, wenn Google damit nichts Böses macht, auch bietet dem Nutzer den meisten Mehrwert, wenn die Daten verarbeitet werden können.
Das heißt im Prinzip, also von manchen Leuten her, dass die Daten nicht mehr verarbeitet werden können, ist einfach doch eine gute Sache. Jenny zum Beispiel, die muss mit Google arbeiten.
Hallo. Hallo, schönen guten Abend.
Wieso das?
Ja, ich bin da, hallo.
Wieso musst du mit Google arbeiten?
Weil ich AdWords betreue. Das sind diese kleinen Anzeigen, die in der Google-Suche ganz oben und rechts stehen.
Für eine Firma, für mehrere Firmen?
Für mittlerweile nur noch eine Firma.
Weil sich das nicht lohnt oder?
Es lohnt sehr. Es lohnt, dass ich es nur noch für eine Firma tun muss.
Verstehe. Und nutzt du Google auch noch privat?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Dadurch bin ich total Google-affin. Ich habe eine Google-Mail-Adresse. Ich benutze alle möglichen Oberflächen, die man sich vorstellen kann. Aber Dokumente teile ich noch nicht.
Wenn du mit den AdWords arbeitest, erfährt man da irgendetwas? Oder was lernst du da? Oder nach welchen Kriterien arbeitest du da mit den AdWords?
Ich habe eine Art Segmente zur Verfügung, wo ich Werbung schalten kann. Ich hätte zu den Zielworten, die dort eingetippt werden, vom Kunden oder vom Suchenden. Dazu passt es ja. Aber es geht ja noch viel weiter, dass Webseiten angemeldet sind bei Google, die dann auch Banner ausliefern und auch Texten zeigen. Das wird zu bestimmten Schlagworten ausgeliefert, die der Kunde hinterlässt und worum sich die Webseite handelt. Viel wird auch in Foren ausgeliefert. Als Marketer ist das natürlich total spannend.
Aber die Dinge, die du hast zu sagen, ist es einfach nur Werbestatistik im Sinne von, du weißt welche AdWords erfolge sind? Oder glaubst du, dass man, wenn man weiß, nach welchen Worten jemand sucht, dass man auch sagen kann, was für eine Person das ist?
Nein, das kann man natürlich nicht. Also ich kann nicht auf die IP-Adresse runterbrechen.
Das ist schon klar, aber vom Personenprofil, also du machst ja schon wahrscheinlich Gedanken drum, wer was verkunden möchte, meinen Kunden an...
Genau, also ich kann das Alter, Geschlecht und so weiter. Solche Sachen sind durchaus möglich.
Wie funktioniert das?
Das bietet sozusagen diese AdWords-Oberfläche im Bereich Content.
Ich möchte gar nicht, dass diese Werbung von 14-jährigen männlichen Jugendlichen gesehen wird.
Genau. Also ich möchte, dass wenn... Sofern Google darauf Zugriff hat, ja wir haben ja nicht auf allen Webseiten diesen Zugriff auf die Daten, aber dort wo sie es haben, ja.
Weißt du, wo man das herkriegt? Also wo Google die Daten herkriegt?
Ähm, ja durch die Profile, die hinterlegt sind. Also ich nehme mal irgendein Forum, das ist nur richtig groß, und da sind irgendwelche Leute angemeldet mit ihrem Namen, mit ihrem Geburtsdatum, mit dem Ort, wo sie leben. Das ist ja auch eine ganz interessante Sache, dass ich Werbung treiben kann, dass ich sagen kann, ich möchte genau jemanden in Berlin Mitte erreichen, der dann auch noch am besten männlich ist. Ich meine, das engt natürlich als Marketingtreibender das total ein, aber natürlich total spannend das zu tun. Das ist einfach nur eine Schablone, die ich ausfülle.
Das ist aber schon ein gutes Beispiel, an dem man sehen kann, dass es nicht unbedingt die ganz persönlichen Schreckensszenarien sind, von wegen jemand kann rausfinden, was ich ganz persönlich gemacht habe, sondern auch ganz banal eben, ja.
Dass ich halt etwas zugeschnittenes bekomme, also viele, ich bin ja selber ganz oft erschrocken, wenn ich mein E-Mail-Postfach aufmache und vorher mit meiner Schwester über die Wohnungsgestaltung gesprochen habe, per E-Mail, welche Wandfarbe sie benutzt und bald in einer Stunde später bekomme ich die perfekt passenden Adwords drumherum. Also selbst mich erschreckt das noch, aber da sieht man auch, wie gut das System funktioniert.
Aber das, sagen, führt nicht dazu, dass du dein Verhalten änderst?
Nein.
Loggst du dich bei Google aus, bevor du suchst?
Ähm, nein.
Nein oder nicht immer?
Also ich filogentiere wirklich meine Kugels selbstverständlich, also das ist irgendwie so Berufskrankheit wahrscheinlich.
Warum das?
Weil man dann glaubt, dass man eben so ein bisschen entkommt.
Bleibst du bei Google weiterhin eingeduckt?
Nein, bestimmt auch nicht immer, aber doch über eine Tagesnutzung schon, ja.
Hat sich dein Verhältnis zu Kugels und diesem Einloggen und Ausloggen verändert durch deine Arbeit?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich hatte vorher gar kein Bewusstsein, also wirklich gar nicht und bin Schritt für Schritt, also eigentlich eher noch so über andere Bereiche dazu gekommen, wie viel man tatsächlich ablegen kann, also wie so ein Protokoll tatsächlich aussieht. Und ich fand das unglaublich. Ich bin überhaupt nicht auf über die technische Schiene daran gekommen, sondern halt von dieser Marketing Schiene. Und klar, das ist natürlich ein Traum, irgendwie eine C-Gruppe so einengen zu können, aber selber zu C-Gruppen zu gehören, das ist natürlich auch ein komisches Gefühl gewesen. Aber gerade was so andere Social-Geschichten auch angeht und auch Google Mail mit allem drum und dran, da ist der Spaßfaktor denn oft wichtiger als die Sicherheit. Das ist ganz verblüffend.
Also beobachtest du bei anderen Leuten?
Bei mir selber.
Bei dir selber?
Ja, obwohl mir das relativ bewusst ist, geh ich da doch sehr offen mit um.
Ist das sozusagen auch so eine Art, dass du quasi gute Vorsätze hast, die du aber nicht einhältst?
Ja, so ungefähr, kann man schon sagen. Ich sehe Google halt nicht als große Bedrohung. Ich habe einfach aufgehört, diese Diskussion weiter zu führen. Aber es ist für mich auch eine endlose Diskussion. Wir hatten ja jetzt auch schon in der Sendung verschiedene Beispiele dafür, dass man sich auch wirklich kaputt machen kann. Weil ich finde es jetzt wie gesagt, ich wollte einfach nur mal diese Sichtweise reinbringen, weil sich ja viele auch immer fragen, warum machen die das? Die machen Kohle damit, das ist ganz eindeutig. Umso besser die Anzeigen in einem bestimmten Werbeumfeld passen, umso mehr klicken die Leute drauf, umso mehr verdienen Google.
Das glaube ich genau, dass Spagat den Googler betreiben muss. Auf der einen Seite die Werbegründen zufriedenstellen, aber auf der anderen Seite über die Nutzer nur so viele Daten rausgeben, wie sie müssen, und auf dem Rest der Daten sitzen bleiben und gucken, dass nichts passiert und keine negative PR kommt.
Ja, und das ist ja auch, wenn man an die Suchanfragen selber, also auf der Suchschule, wo man sozusagen denkt, dann sieht man ja auch, also es würde alles nicht funktionieren, wenn die nicht Daten speichern würden, dann könnten sie das System nicht verbessern und das ernährt sich ja davon, dass Leute einen bestimmten Weg immer und immer wieder gehen. Also das ist einfach, dieser Algorithmus beinhaltet ja genau das. Das bedingt sich gegenseitig. Es gibt, weil wir jetzt auch irgendwie bei dem Thema waren, was gibt es für Alternativlösungen? Keine Ahnung.
Mir stellt sich gerade noch eine Frage, du arbeitest ja selber damit und findest es geil, weil du halt deine Werbung so einschränken kannst, und dass du genau schalten kannst. Andererseits ist dir dabei ein bisschen komisch. Würdest du, wenn sozusagen oder andersrum, wie viel wäre es dir wert, in Geld, in Euro ausgedrückt, sozusagen, dass du genau dieselbe Komfort, also Bequemlichkeit haben kannst, aber dir wird garantiert, dass deine Daten dann nicht mehr weiterverarbeitet werden?
Würde ich eh keinem glauben.
Richtiger Antwort, ja.
Also das ist einfach zu verführerisch, diese Daten zu verwenden. Wie gesagt, es ist ja eigentlich nur eine Maschine, in die ich etwas eingebe und ich bekomme etwas wieder. Und wie soll jemand meine Daten nicht versenden? Wie soll der etwas optimieren können? Woran macht er das fest? Also ich würde es ihm nicht glauben.
Okay, und sozusagen selbst gesetzt den Fall, es gäbe jetzt sozusagen so eine magische Black Box, wo das irgendwie funktionieren würde, mich würde halt diese Summe interessieren, ob es für dich tatsächlich so eine Art Wert hat, oder ob du schon gesagt hast, okay, das ist halt einfach so.
Ja, ich wollte gerade sagen, also da bin ich wahrscheinlich es genau so, dass ich irgendwie gemerkt habe jetzt in der ganzen Diskussion, ich bin über den Berg. Ich hab mich ewig, ich find's ganz lustig, eine Freundin von mir hat jetzt bei Facebook irgendwie gepostet, ich bin ein Medien-Dozialist oder so. Und dann gab's halt ein schönes Comic, wie jemand sagt, von wegen Payday-Karte oder so, was schau ich nicht. Und in der nächsten Szene sitzt er halt vor Facebook oder irgendeinem Twitter-Ding und schreibt, dass er irgendwas ganz Intimes tut. Und ich hab mich extrem erwischt gefühlt.
Gibt's irgendwelche Daten, die du...
Also ich nutze keine Payday-Karten, ich find das grauenvoll. Ich sag ständig zu irgendwelchen Frauen an den Kassen, ich möchte kein lesender Kunde sein. Und arbeite aber auf einem ganz anderen Gebiet total ähnlich.
Gibt's irgendwelche Daten, die du Google nicht anvertrauen würdest?
Ja, selbstverständlich.
Du sollst jetzt nicht die Daten ja ausbreiten, aber unter welche Kategorie fallen die?
Privat ist das Privatleben. Also meine Beziehung, mein Kind, mein...
Aber das bedeutet eigentlich, in der Mail, die du über Google verschickst, dürftest du dann nicht über dein Kind schreiben?
Google mich nach Kinderspielzeugen suchen, das fand ich auch ziemlich scary. Sie haben beim Super Bowl, was so ziemlich die teuerste Werbezeit in den USA ist, hat Google eine Werbung gehabt mit einer Sucheingabe-Box, wo jemand sich erst erkundigt hat nach ja, na, how to impress a French woman job in Paris and how to build a crib. Das fand ich ziemlich scary.
Weil?
Weil das einem doch vor Augen führt, dass jede Frage an Google eine Antwort für Google ist. Wenn ich Google nach was frage, dann ist das, sagt man damit, ich habe Interesse an einer bestimmten Sache. Ich habe eine bestimmte Fragestellung, die mich bewegt. Da kann man Rückschlüsse ziehen.
Und das glaube ich genau.
Also klar, wenn jemand sich richtig Mühe geben würde, könnte er über mich auch sonst was rausfinden. Also was ich in den letzten Jahren zusammen gegoogelt habe, ist wahrscheinlich auch unglaublich. Und ich bin total dankbar aber für diesen Informationszugang. Also ich meine, viele kennen ja auch gar nicht die ganzen Möglichkeiten von Google. Ich bin nur ein ganz großer Fan geworden über die Zeit. Also schon dieses Cola oder Book Search oder weiss ich irgendwas.
Also zusammengefasst kann man sagen, Jenny findet Google total toll, aber es ist doch irgendwie ein komisches Gefühl, genau zu wissen.
Also es ist natürlich bedrückend und in solchen Diskussionen kommt einem auch immer wieder seltsam vor, sicherlich. Und ich bin auch durchaus umgeben von Menschen, die es sehr, sehr kritisch sehen. Also die Diskussion ist nicht alltäglich, aber fast.
Gut, und bei dir wird sich auf jeden Fall auch nichts ändern.
Vielleicht habe ich mal ein brutales Erlebnis, keine Ahnung, hoffentlich nicht.
Da sind wir immer noch auf der Suche. Alles klar, falls sich da noch jemand meldet, dann anrufen 0331 70 97 110. Vielen Dank Jenny. So jetzt müssen wir uns aber langsam schon richtig beeilen.
Moment, wir singen ja jetzt noch schwule Mädchen in der Zugabe und so. Aber ich fand das jetzt auf jeden Fall noch mal so gegen Ende genau auf den Punkt gebracht. Diese Ambivalenz zwischen toll, nützlich und will ich haben und eben genau diesem mulmigen Gefühl. Das ist einfach gerade noch mal schön auf den Punkt gebracht. Und das mit den Adwords, dass es diese Schablone da gibt, war mir auch gar nicht so bewusst.
Vor allem auch diese Daten, dass man wirklich sagen kann, ich möchte Personen in einer Zielgruppe von bis aus.
Ja, ich meine, das gab es früher auch schon von Dienstleistern, aber jetzt ist es halt einfach im Web und für jeden halt zugänglich.
Bei Facebook geht das auch. Da kann man auch klicken sozusagen. Ich möchte gerne Werbung machen für Leute zwischen die aus Berlin kommen.
Spezifisch auf Facebook bei Google ist das Besondere, dass diese Werbung eben nicht nur auf einer Seite ist. Und dass über diese AdSense Geschichte das auf...
Du gehst halt auf Google Maps, guckst jetzt eine Straße nach und plopp, sind in der Cyber gleich mal die entsprechenden Geschäfte wurde da einer.
Das gehört so. Jetzt haben wir noch einen. Weil wir vorhin auch über Streetview geredet hatten. Du wärst enttäuscht, lese ich hier, wenn ein Haus nicht drin wäre.
Ja. Ich war für Quatschhalter. Ich halte es für übertrieben, diese Geschichte mit dem das Recht am eigenen Bild auf das Recht am eigenen Haus auszudehnen. Ich halte es einfach für Blödsinn. Es wird heutzutage, wenn man das konsequent zu Ende denkt, wird es fast völlig unmöglich gemacht, irgendwo in der Öffentlichkeit noch irgendein Foto zu machen. Und das sei es kommerziell zu verwenden oder auch privat zu verwenden. Weil was ist denn private Verwendung, wenn ich sie veröffentliche? Ich lege das auf irgendeinen Webstore ab und letzten Endes ist es dann ja doch wieder irgendwo wahrscheinlich auf dem Dienst von einer kommerziellen Firma, die letztes Jahr ist damit Geld verdient. Also im Prinzip müsste ich es komplett verbieten.
Also du meinst irgendwie, das ist sowieso jetzt soweit und wir stellen einfach unsere Daten auch ins Netz. Dafür erstmal vielen Dank. Wir müssen jetzt ein bisschen beeilen, weil wir haben noch drei Leute, aber fast nicht mehr so viel Zeit dafür.
Christopher, wie siehst du das?
Ich sehe es so entweder ganz oder gar nicht.
Heißt?
Entweder ich will das Internet nutzen und muss damit klarkommen, dass irgendwo immer was gespeichert wird. Ob ich jetzt Google nicht nutze oder es nutze.
Wo immer Sachen gelockt und mitgeschrieben werden.
Ich sag mal so, wenn es jetzt eine Firma macht oder ganz viele, wenn ich jetzt das Ganze aussplitte, email, dann mein Telefon, dann habe ich meinen Internetzugang da noch. Man muss einfach irgendwo auch ein bisschen Vertrauen haben und wie ja auch schon gesagt wurde, euch ist ja auch keine Panne bei Google bekannt.
Aber einer Bank...
Willst du dein Telefonbuch einfach vertrauen?
Ich sag mal so, ja, es ist ja dann nur eine einzige Person und nicht erstmal so eine riesengroße Community, die da drauf zugrafen könnte oder die... Ich denk mal, Google könnte das dann besser vermarkten als er.
Ich bin sehr vertrauenswürdig.
Ja, ich meine, gut, der Hintertun, den du da so durchblicken lässt, ist natürlich dann eher der da nicht so dann auf Vertrauen steht.
Nein, ich bin da total vertrauenswürdig, auf jeden Fall.
Nein, also ehrlich.
Ich würde auch nur RGB...
Was mir jetzt noch nicht rauskommt, würdest du es bevorzugen, wenn verschiedene Leute deine Daten sammeln, was ja sowieso passiert, wie du sagst, oder ist es auch okay, wenn es eine einzelne große Firma macht?
Es ist in gewisser Weise egal, ja.
Okay, behältst du dich dann sozusagen, also dir ist das klar, das gehört dazu, hältst du dich in irgendeiner Art und Weise zurück, oder ist es einfach so, dass du für dich entschieden hast, okay, meine Daten werden jetzt gesammelt, ist mir egal?
Nee, also man hält sich natürlich jetzt schon zurück, indem man sagt, nur die Sachen, die man auch nach außen geben will, wie jetzt zum Beispiel vielleicht den Vornamen, oder wie hab ich ja jetzt auch preisgegeben zum Beispiel, und dass man halt sagt, jetzt nicht irgendwie sein Tagebuch, so was dann halt.
Aber das heißt auch so sagen, du dürftest nicht mehr nach Dingen in der Suchmaschine suchen, die privat sind.
Ja gut, was ist denn wieder privat? Und wenn ich jetzt nach meinem Tagebuch google, wenn ich mir Sachen kaufe zum Beispiel, wenn ich da nach google, ob das jetzt privat ist, es ist natürlich ein Interesse, die dann von Google vielleicht wieder zu Geld gemacht wird. Und ich denke, wenn ich jetzt wirklich was auf dem Kerbholz hab und dann Vaterstaat sagt, wir haben einen Beschluss, gibt uns jetzt mal das Profil, das Genaue. Ich finde, dass dann was auch schon gesagt wurde, man darf sich da nicht allzu hysterisch machen. Ich hätte dann eher Angst, dass dann irgendwann mal eine Panne kommt. Und dann schon fertige Profile dann quasi einem zur Verfügung stehen.
Aber das passiert ja, weil, wie du sagst, Daten werden sowieso gesammelt. Christopher, vielen Dank. Jetzt haben wir noch schnell den Tobias.
Ja, hi.
Schönen guten Abend.
Ach, ganz schnell.
Ja, so ganz schnell, wenn das überhaupt möglich ist. Geht eigentlich so ein bisschen um etwas der neueren Entwicklung von Google, nämlich Google Wave, was quasi so noch gar nicht erwähnt wurde. Ja, ich würd mal erst mal sagen, so Ersteindruck, so ein bisschen Suspect, relativ komisch. Also es geht ja quasi um das kollaborative Arbeiten an Dokumenten, an Projekten und an Präsentationen etc. Nur, ja, so wo es denn...
Okay, warte mal, es ist zwei vor zwölf ganz konkrete Frage. Was ist deine Frage oder dein Standpunkt?
Es ist ja nur wirklich sehr suspicious, dass Google, also ich hab direkt so immer das Gefühl gehabt, egal was ich da direkt schreibe, Google lief mit und wunderbar, egal was jetzt passiert, Google weiß es. Egal was für ein Projekt ich jetzt gerade mit irgendwelchen Bekannten zusammenschricke, Google könnte es verwenden, benutzen, die Ideen klauen.
Die spannende Frage ist, hält dich das irgendwie davon ab, Google zu benutzen?
Google Wave definitiv.
Was benutzt du stattdessen?
Google Suche, natürlich.
Was benutzt du statt Google Wave oder machst du keine online Zusammenarbeit mit anderen Leuten?
Das ist eben das Problem. Man muss eben Projekte halbwegs fertig machen und dann per Docfile oder sonstiges halt eben rübersenden. Also die Idee an sich finde ich mehr als nur genial, dass man eben direkt in der Zusammenarbeit in einem Text arbeiten kann, direkt sehen kann, was für Veränderungen gemacht wurden und die idealerweise auch editieren kann. Nur die Gesamtlösung, dass ein großer Konzern eben darüber steht und du nicht weißt, wo jetzt deine Daten überhaupt landen oder wie sie überhaupt gesichert werden können, das ist so ein großer Knackpunkt, der mich dann halt doch so ein bisschen davon abhält, Google Wave als effektive, firmeffiziente Lösung für Projektarbeiten zu benutzen.
Kann man also subsumieren unter Google oder Allgemeinen, oder gibt es in Zukunft Dienste, die einem das Leben leichter machen und man muss dafür eben eine Handvoll Daten hergeben, um diese Dienste zu bekommen? Wo man dann für sich persönlich die Entscheidung trifft, was für Daten bin ich da bereit reinzugeben, wo suche ich mir meine Alternativen, um noch einen kleinen Ausblick in die Zukunft zu werfen. Google ist in den USA gerade dabei, zum Internet Service Provider zu werden. Dazu muss man sagen, dass Google für Bandbreite momentan nicht wirklich was zahlen muss, weil jeder mit Google Daten austauschen möchte. Da geht die Zukunft hin, Google bietet heute schon einen offenen DNS-Service an. Also es bleibt weiter spannend. Die Daten werden mehr die Möglichkeiten, mit diesen Daten umzugehen werden mehr. Das muss, glaube ich, jeder für sich selbst die Lösung finden.
Und die Informationen wollen frei sein.
Das sollte einfach nochmal gesagt werden, habe ich Eindruck.
Also, Daten sind wie Wasser. Das kannst du halt nicht zusammenhalten. Und das fließt schon immer irgendwo der Gravitation nach.
Jetzt wird es gerade ganz schön leter, Jungs.
Nein, das ist total sozusagen die Essenz des Ganzen.
Was für mich die Essenz des Ganzen ist, dass sich ziemlich viele Leute so ein bisschen unwohl damit fühlen. Und denken, naja, irgendwie ist es schon komisch. Aber andererseits, wir benutzen es halt auch einfach, weil es so geil, schön funktioniert. Was daraus geworden ist, das können wir dann vielleicht einfach in einem Jahr besprechen.
Vor allen Dingen, aber was mich jetzt nochmal als Schlusspunkt echt fasziniert, es hat jetzt echt keine angerufen, der irgendwie eine negative Erfahrung damit gemacht hat. Also sie haben ihren Job halt auch echt verdammt gut gemacht, scheinbar. Also wenn wirklich niemand, der da jetzt irgendwie sich äußert, irgendeinen schlechten Clip mit Google gehabt hat. Also das ist auf jeden Fall auch sehr beeindruckend. Und für mich fast noch ein Grund mehr, das irgendwie mit einem mulmigen Gefühl zu beobachten.
Da kuckelt er heute beim Chaosradio dabei war. Auch Nibbler war dabei. Wir haben über Google gesprochen. Im Podcast gibt es wahrscheinlich ziemlich schnell in einschlägigen Quellen fritz.de oder chaosradio.de. Könnt ihr einfach so klicken. Jetzt kommt gleich Tobias Koch mit dem Night Flight. Wir sind raus und sagen...
Schwule Mädchen.
Wollte ich eigentlich nicht sagen. Ich wollte eigentlich den schönen Satz sagen, macht immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen.